okay here we are it's Monday right
yeah it is Monday January 30th
and uh we are here with
someone I'm very excited
to talk to today someone's whose career
I've been tracking
Rebecca Black the one and only
yeah
I'm so excited to be here thank you
today's episode is sponsored by Kudos
thank you to them so Rebecca Black is
here I think everybody knows who you are
which is kind of interesting
um how are you doing I'm good I'm good
I'm good definitely
definitely doing better than
previous times previously okay that's
good we had a good time yeah nice I'm
glad to hear it so um first of all right
at the top I want to say that uh
your first album debut full length album
let her burn is coming out on the 9th of
February that's fine
awesome
I'm excited I know a lot of people are
giving me a little bit of sh can you
yeah you can see it
um a lot of people are going to say see
you next Tuesday really YouTube for
whatever reason they put the kibosh on
that word apparently that sounds like
they say it's like a hate word against
women no it's like at this point I feel
like it's become like less of a slur
than at least in like gay culture and
um well good to know anyway
um
yeah I've gotten a lot of [__] for the
fact that like it's been 12 years and
it's a debut album but it took me some
time it took some time well that's but
you're not coming from nothing I mean
you've been putting out EPs and singles
and stuff so you've been active yeah
yeah I mean I I needed to figure it all
out you know I like everything happens
so unexpectedly I was like a YouTuber
mainly for a while like I've done a lot
of different things but yeah it's it's
good so that's exciting and also I want
to say that if you guys want to go to
her
website uh rebeccablock dot Co slash
shows you're also on tour right wow yes
Shredder God damn that's right your dad
is excited he's excited just stop
whatever you're doing anything that does
said Shredder on he's feeling better he
he actually was in the hospital for oh
no no kidney damage oh my God yeah he
did almost die not to bum you up but
he's in a pretty good mood these days
okay guys making up for a lot I'm so
glad he's with us yeah me too
um thank you for the tour shout out yeah
I'm heading to uh the UK this week wow
or
um for my first run there it is so
Rebecca Black is out there
um you're 25 now I'm 25. and you were 13
when Friday originally came out is that
right yes okay yeah
yeah so I kind of want to I kind of want
to start from kind of the beginning go
back a little bit I want to learn about
you and your families and stuff like
that sure sure sure so
um
where where are you from I'm from Orange
County I'm from Anaheim oh you're from
here yeah okay well I mean I'm
definitely not from LA but like I'm from
Southern California yeah
and you mentioned to me that both of
your parents are veterinarians yeah
interesting yes
yes Mom is my dad's boss my brother
lives with them like your brother works
with them yes do you have that too or
like well he's 23.
so you know he's like just learning and
kind of assisting and all of that but uh
but yeah no I'm definitely like the only
one out here doing something not in that
world okay and um
did you always how did this interest in
music come about because obviously
you're pretty young when when Friday
came out was that something that you had
always wanted to do or was it something
you just did on a whim for fun like
how'd that come about I mean I I grew up
as a kid who was always performing like
I was a dancer when I was three from the
time I was like probably 13 and
um I was always in like theater camps
and performance groups I was in some
like really cringe like patriotic
performing groups at one point just as
like a kid oh like uh like tell me about
it it's really cute
I mean we would base basically just the
group was called
celebration USA I don't know if I've
ever mentioned this but like it was just
like I was 11 and that was actually when
I first started singing was through that
group and you would just go and perform
at like retirement homes like veteran
bases
um you know those kinds of things we
sang like the national anthem at the
Angel Stadium once
um and yeah we were just saying like
what were you guys wearing like glitter
American flag wow right red lipstick the
pantyhose
it was a Vibe it was a Vibe so you were
always interested in singing so how did
the yeah this idea for Friday come
together well I was in musical I was in
a musical theater program at my school
in middle school and I had a friend who
um like over the summer just like one
day like she like had a music video and
like all my friends were in it and they
filmed it at the school and I was like
that's
crazy like how did you do that and um
yeah she just I like asked her about it
one day and she just mentioned that
she'd worked with this company and
um that yeah like it was like kind of
like a little thing she got to do okay
so
the company that produced your video I
remember because
they've made a lot of other [__] that
I've talked about I have a very intimate
um knowledge of Arc Factory music and
Patrice Wilson I um and so you heard
that your friend had worked with him and
she's like oh you should go check work
with these people yes just like oh yeah
it's this thing
this thing called like oh I'll go
okay that's cool because I don't know I
was like very I was very passionate
about like music performing really
performing was like my big thing like I
was always like probably like the most
annoying kid in musical theater about
like taking it seriously and I thought
like at that point like I mean I was 13.
so like I wasn't even in high school yet
but I was like maybe I'll go to
Juilliard or like maybe I'll go to NYU
and like end up in New York on Broadway
or something and um and so I checked it
out
and like my mom has always been really
supportive of me and my brother I mean
she's come she's Hispanic she's from
Mexico and like her style of parenting
has always just been like whatever you
want to do if you have like a love like
let's do it I love that even when she
didn't really have the means to do it
she would pull some crazy [__] and like
I don't know she would help my brother
get into like club soccer or like
something whatever she thought we liked
um and so I just had told her about it
as I was looking it up and she was like
oh well we should like let's check it
out like maybe it's a cool experience
that you can put on your resume and like
you know having been in a recording
studio and so I think she literally like
emailed company sorry that's my bad
um I think she like emailed the company
and then set it up yeah I've always
wondered if it's like when I see a kid
do something like this I always wonder
is it like the parent pushing totally
but it sounds like I know in your case
it totally came from you yeah yeah I
mean I my mom was always really
supportive
um
and and both my parents I mean
I think they just like wanted me to find
a passion yeah I don't know I love that
my parents have always been lucky to be
like I've always wanted to be a vet and
so as soon as they saw that I had
something that I maybe wanted to do they
were like well okay yeah
um but no I mean if anything especially
after the fact with Friday they were
like you really want to keep doing this
are you insane
um let's convince you not to because
look at how poorly this comes out the
first time
um but yeah no I mean I have been very
lucky that like my parents have been the
one thing that have never
taken advantage that's really good I
think it was obvious that there was a
supportive parent behind that video
like I mean was it it looked at least
kind of expensive to put together but I
don't know what he very gracious
they're not that bad like the video
itself is well produced I was wondering
it's pretty good like the audio quality
like say what you will about Patrice but
the guy knows how to throw a video
together I
a company
do the video and
we literally shot it like at my dad's
house at the time all my friends were in
it oh okay you know it was like there
the wind in one of the moments where I'm
like in the car is literally a leaf
blower and like that's awesome green
screens of like cardboard
I mean the reason we weren't in a school
bus was because they couldn't afford it
like let's rent uh do you remember how
much it cost I've always been curious
like a few thousand I mean I think that
I know that there was like an agreement
of like well here you can pay four grand
and like that's all you got to do and
this will cover owning the song or
whatever but
um and so I know that that was a thing
but I actually I don't even know what
the video I have to imagine it cost more
than that but I was like so uninvolved
in those conversations and so um
the process how long did it take to
shoot the video like 12 hours oh wow so
you hey you had a long that's a long
shoot day yeah the whole day yeah yeah
my first pick my first big shoot
um yeah I mean it was it was fun like it
was literally just me and my friends and
you know like hanging out at home I
gotta get my makeup done like it was
just a cool experience literally so
you're it seems like your intention
going into that
was um just have just have fun and make
a cool video like your your friend whose
video you saw did she post it online or
anything like that yeah I did yeah well
I think that the the
I guess I didn't even realize like
whether it was Arc or if it was you know
her that put it online was there even an
idea of like oh people are going to want
to watch this if I put it online there
was a moment when when we were like we
first met with them that uh Patrice was
like
you know or one of them I honestly don't
remember was like if we if you put this
up and like it gets 100 000 views like
maybe you can make some money like
that's really cool yeah and I was
literally like okay okay I don't know I
watched like Ryan Higa and like Shane
Dawson at the time and Fred and like all
those like classic you know people and I
was like there's literally no [__]
way we're ever gonna get a hundred
thousand people from the little video
and like it's not like their videos were
known for being popular either at the
time right so they just didn't get Ark
Music Factory didn't get any views on
their stuff
they were the big blowout for them it
was definitely
it's like big moment that they had
um so for me it was like there was okay
maybe we'll send this to a label or to
an agency or like whatever the music
industry garbled was that they used but
like
um for me it was mainly like I get to
see what it's like to be in a recording
studio I get to and I know that's like a
crazy experience that a parent could
give you as a child but like no it is my
mom wanted to do that for me for
whatever reason
um to support me and her being as like
clueless as I was as how anything worked
that was just what
it seems like there's probably
a lot of
you you and your family have probably
been on the I know a receiving end of a
lot of crap one of them I have to guess
is like this this uh claim of you being
like a nepo baby or that your parents
are rich or something like that right
back right I wish I was an EPO baby but
there's got to be a lot of people who
are like oh you're so rich you just paid
to make this shitty video and like I
mean
people will like
I I almost feel like I can't comment on
you know like
whether or not my parents were rich or
not because what I felt at the time and
like what some people would consider you
know wealthy or anything like that like
I feel like I don't I'm not here to
speak on like well I deserve to have
this more or less because of whatever
that was I mean I can tell you my mom
was a single mom who worked three jobs
and wanted to do something for her kid
that was nice and she often
overstretched herself I mean I love my
dad but like he didn't understand what I
was doing so he was never a piece of
that
um and there have been a lot of like
crazy rumors about
it being like a birthday present for a
bat mitzvah of mine but like I'm not
even Jewish yeah that's all
um and you know all these other rumors
of what it was or anything but like yeah
it was a super fortunate opportunity
that I got to have
um
and you know my parents did the best
they can but I also like I mean I'm out
here doing this on my own yeah you know
so so the lyrics to the original one was
that an arc Factory original like or did
you guys work on that together no I did
not change a single thing so they bring
you the music they bring you the lyrics
and you guys probably rehearse it so
what was your what's your first reaction
like this is kind of a banger or
um like you know I mean they sent me
another song before that was called
Superwoman or something like that I've
always tried to find it but I can't find
it anywhere but it was like some like
little love song about like being a
superwoman for a boy or whatever and I
was just like 13. do this I just broke
up with my boyfriend because I couldn't
talk to him at school right I am in no
position to be no Superwoman
um and so I I said like uh do you guys
have anything else sorry but
um
but then they sent me it was called It's
Friday at the time and I was just like
cute okay whatever also like who am I
gonna be to ask for another song the
third time even maybe I was just like
nobody's gonna see this like let's just
run it you know
um it's the most it's more true than
like me being a Superwoman I'm right
it's Friday I mean that's that's Friday
yeah yeah yeah and so okay so they bring
you this song you agree you're like okay
it's Friday it's kind of a vibe
and you guys shot it with all your
friends at your dad's house
and so
one day I have to imagine that they went
back they edit it they put it together
and then they sent you a final version
no absolutely not that's not what
happened it went up
it just went up online before you ever
even saw it oh yeah well I know I know
what
um wait so we shot it
um actually funnily enough we shot at
January 6th of totally Twenty One Eleven
yeah January January so it was a it was
a premonition day yeah it was you
stormed Friday that day
[Laughter]
um we shot it in January and at the time
that we shot the video or before we shot
the video there was no rap verse on it
at all it was just me what and then that
day Patrice came and obviously it was
gonna be like on sex company and he was
like hey I put a verse in it and I was
like all right
and he shot it in my
um he shot it in my dad's like Ford
Escape in our garage
at your house yes and then my dad
knocked it in
well no I mean we knew at that he was
just like there's a verse in the song I
got I got a I got some fire on about
this bit
and then um yeah that is what it was
that scene is so awesome oh my God
because it's just like it is like so out
of [__] place and it's like who is
this guy why is he rapping why is he
like talking about the school bus and
it's like an adult in a kid's world it's
a Vibe it's a Vibe it's added to the
just a little bizarreness
it did add to the bizarreness
um and so we shot in like early January
and then I didn't hear anything from
them or my family didn't for like weeks
and like I actually kind of forgot that
it happened right and like every now and
again like some of the kids at school
would be like hey like did that video
ever like get finished like we'd love to
see it and
um and then literally one day I Got a
notification from their website that it
had gone out wow out Rebecca Black's new
single Friday and I watched it I can't
believe that I know I know I watched it
in bed by myself and I was like
semi-mortified
mainly because I had like this massive
pimple on my cheek that like I think
there were rumors it was a war no it was
a and um I was just like okay and then I
watched it with my dad I showed my dad
and we were like okay that's the video
that's a video yeah yeah I just can't
believe like as somebody that's been
through working on videos and then
posting it I know I can't believe that
like decision being taken away from you
and especially when you're not a
professional and such a vulnerable
moment yeah I'm shocked I mean I know it
is crazy looking back now but I I have
no idea how any of that works so I was
just like um that's what happened
probably didn't even think about it
going right you don't no not really yeah
you know I mean like I knew they had a
website
and but even when it went on YouTube
like I wasn't like I've been exposed
like I was up there with like however
many thousands of videos were getting
uploaded every second yeah under the
radar I was like all right
um so you got it you watched it mm-hmm
were you what did you think of the song
in the video and everything at first I
mean as a 13 year old I think I was
probably more concerned about like
myself than anything yeah like I was so
hyper focused on this is what I look
like on camera and like this video yeah
like just picking my own self apart and
like I look a little awkward there and
like all of those things rather than
because this was never meant to be like
this is my pop star debut yeah like I
was literally just on my own Vibe like I
didn't really consider it to be
something that was going to be seen by a
lot of people so yeah
um yeah I think that that was mostly
what I was concerned about and
um and like again like my biggest
priorities were like Justin Bieber
um you know like my friends I was like I
hope my friends think this is cool right
or like not weird
um yeah I mean everyone was like cute it
was fun yeah it wasn't that serious no
and like we were a kid it's very
impressive maybe yeah and like I mean
there were a couple kids who would like
sing it at school but it wasn't like
really a thing you know until a few
months later when it went viral and then
you know that was different so
oh here's the pimple is that okay if I
pull it up please we have the receipts
we've come we've come to peace with the
pimple so yeah there she I didn't even
notice it if that makes you my little my
first ever pimple really wow that was
why I was immortalized for hundreds of
years
history he made first three yeah
um and like I yeah I mean
yeah so you see the video
how long before
other people start watching it it was a
couple months a couple months yeah I
would like check in on it every couple
weeks was it going up at all or not
really I think
it I checked it I I only remember these
numbers because I've talked about them
so many times but like I checked it a
few days or a few weeks before like it
really popped and it had like 3 000
views you know that's that's actually
not not crazy
yeah
a private video basically yeah yeah I
mean it was like that was pretty similar
I think to what other [__] had on and
what what were the were you reading the
comments at that time when I had like
three thousand probably yeah
um were they like supportive or confused
or what was the vibe I think it was a
little bit of everything yeah yeah it
was like okay q and also like who the
[__] is this ugly [__] and you know all
the really appropriate things to say to
a 13 year old all right so after a
couple months
um it's slowly getting views do you know
was there a catalyst that set this thing
off yeah oh how the hell did they find
it I don't even think he found it I
think somebody he had like a
what would you even call that like
somewhere where like his audience I
think could submit videos on like the
site and so somebody found it and was
just like LOL at the songwriting so what
was his coverage like
yeah I actually did something with Tosh
um oh that's cool it was like the
10-year anniversary or something like
that or maybe it was nine years actually
it was nine I wish I could watch this
clip of him talking about but I'm sure I
don't know if he ever even talked about
it it was just like on the website right
um and then it like blew up oh no yeah
well no that's old that's definitely old
so maybe he did talk about it I've
actually never seen this really wait can
you guys see if this gets claimed yeah
unless this is oh no this is the new one
this is the new one when I went oh yeah
this is two years ago I like did a whole
reclam yeah we did like some spoof NPR
tiny dust can you guys find a stupid
joke yeah
can you guys find the original one if
possible yeah okay this is cool this is
cool how was that experience yeah I was
really scared yeah um but it was he was
really cool you know I mean he was
really nice and
um I mean sorry this is it Ethan I'll
keep checking huh sorry this isn't it
I'll keep checking yeah yeah we
established that from a couple years ago
aab next time when she's in the middle
something really personal just go ahead
and whatever's on your thoughts I'm so
sorry
I didn't want you to open it whatever
I'm about to say about myself
um I actually don't remember what I was
talking about what was I talking about
she doesn't the experience I think with
Josh yeah no he was he was um pretty
cool and like I mean I think that
uh you know I I think
what I've found after this experience
especially as I continue to grow up is a
lot of people really didn't understand
how young I was at the time maybe he did
I don't remember but I think meeting me
now like a lot of people who had like
pretty [__] stuff to say about me as a
kid like it's pretty awkward yeah you
know to see the person in front of you
and realize like oh my God like oh my
God I called this 13 year old a dumb
[__] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah really
um
crazy it is something interesting
looking back is
like
that was one of the first times I can
remember on the internet and YouTube
where
everybody was like we can we hate we all
agree that we [__] hate this person
this little girl there was a lot of hate
right so much I mean people like work
irrationally yeah angry at you yeah yeah
yeah which knowing the backstory makes
it even more [__] up because like you
didn't even post it to the internet
I know but I that you know was like
a minute detail once you decide
something is is whatever I mean
uh I like sometimes don't even know what
to say on on the like mass behavior of
it all but I think that this type of
thing has happened before not to compare
myself so closely because totally
different experiences but like
Britney Spears Lindsay Lohan like these
are like all like I mean Monica Lewinsky
like these are all like females who or
women who females not me it's like
females
um women who have like really I I also
got corrected recently or I got in
trouble for saying females it's yeah
educated yeah but sometimes it doesn't
need to be sometimes I don't even know
where it's like you would say female
tennis player
right sure but see that's that's okay
right because if I say a woman tennis
player is that awkward sounding
um I just I stopped saying female it's
gone I think I think it's more so
females like females calling women
females which I didn't mean I think it's
just that the award has been ruined it's
not really wrong like you could say that
this like objectifying term that people
like Andrew Kate will use you know
against women as like a way to not
really call them yeah I didn't know that
but not once someone corrected me on
that yeah or made me aware then I
started hearing people like fresh and
fit Andrew Tate and they go females
that's how you get the females and I was
like oh my God that is really weird how
they use that word it's pretty crazy I
mean I think it I don't want to speak on
this too crazily because I really don't
know but like I think it has to do
probably with like
um
identifying a woman like solely by like
her biological right assets right you
know so that's not what I meant
on my mind so yeah people have like
over the course of history
just like dedicated so much energy to
disparaging women
um just because like they see other
people doing it and it feels for
whatever reason I don't know good or
empowering to do that
um and yeah whether I like it's it's
interesting because I've experienced so
many people say to me like wow I didn't
realize you were 13 or even apologizing
for what they said because they didn't
realize I was 13 when I'm like it really
doesn't matter yeah
um but yeah yeah
so going back a little bit
um so tajpoint did some kind of he
covered the video on his website not
even on TV yeah maybe he did like I
think after it blew up maybe he did like
a little thing but I actually don't
remember and so from that moment was
there kind of like this exponential
growth or how did it go it was literally
that moment that it like
or that day
um that it hit Twitter it hit like all
like probably uh 4chan read it like all
those big yeah but 4chan was definitely
a big part of it at the time
um best people
yeah talking about a 13 year old girl
yeah uh and it literally like from that
day it I mean by the end of the weekend
it was like over a million views and
then wow kept going yeah as it was going
up that must have been pretty surreal
were you like what is happening were you
scared were you excited I was scared
yeah yeah I mean well when I
that day and I kind of saw what was
happening
um and like somebody I saw somebody like
link me to like the Tosh.0 post and then
that put me on the video and I like saw
that it had all these numbers and I was
like whoa I've never been perceived on
the internet like this and then kept
scrolling to the comments and like
everything was just ruthless
and yeah it was horrifying I mean I just
like immediately I think went into shock
and started
crying yeah
that's so sad actually thinking about
how that all played out for you yeah it
was I mean it was scary like because I I
mean I'd had like I think I posted my
own like stupid YouTube video like a few
years before and then I had like one
random like comment that seems like it
was from an older man this is like way
pre-friday just me having fun and I like
immediately deleted all my accounts I
was like no I'm scared of that
um and so that was just like
so
hard to understand and
um and so yeah I mean there was like
questions of like should we delete this
or should you know it stay up and for
whatever reason I decided like
I like let's keep it up
um and that I think was smart just
because there's no there's no way to
stop it at that point
yeah yeah someone would just re-upload
it right re-upload it and then you have
even less control over like whatever
happens to it I mean my parents were
also just like freaking out being like
what do we do and
um were you you guys immediately had
this sense that this is a bad thing this
isn't going to be a good thing
I felt like it was a bad thing yeah yeah
because I mean it was like horrible the
com people were not like oh this song
rules everyone was just like yeah what
kind of comments do you remember reading
that kind of hit you hard as a 13 year
old girl
um
I think the original like Tosh.0 thing
was more so about like oh the lyrics are
stupid but like I I just remember seeing
so many people like pointing out like
everything about me and like just being
like she's ugly she's an idiot she's fat
she's you know just literally like
everything that's crazy and yeah
experiencing like that like Rush of just
comments about you when you've never
experienced that before as a kid and
were you as a kid did you at a certain
point stop reading or did you scroll a
lot and read a lot of the comments
I was scrolling for a while yeah yeah
um it's hard not to it's so hard not to
because it's not just like your YouTube
comments it's your Twitter it's your
insta I mean whenever Instagram became a
thing it's your I mean people were like
finding my like personal Facebook and
like trying to say stuff I mean people
were showing up to my dad's door with
like deliveries and [__] like that and
then there were death like it was just
so insane out of nowhere and it it was
like well you got a million views in
that one day but it kept going right I
mean yeah it became the fastest video to
reach 100 million views really until I
think it was Gangnam Style holy [__] ate
me out let me ask you this
having it been that popular over that
amount of time by the time it hit 100
million views were you still feeling
like this was a bad thing or it was just
like a bad dream that wouldn't end or or
was there a moment where you were able
to accept it
um I mean it was really confusing
because I would
have like this whole thing happening
which felt like the most true version of
what was happening when I would like sit
alone in my room on my computer just
like Doom scrolling
um on my own [__] and then like my you
know all of a sudden my parents are
being like enamored with or tackled with
like all these like help let me help you
out there were you know attorneys and
agents and managers and like let's help
you set this up yep I mean stuff like
that but then also
um people who like in the industry were
like let's help you figure this out and
do this and like how can we make the
most of this and all that
um so I started getting these like
really cool experiences that everyone
around me and I think my parents were
probably trying to make the most like
just trying to help me like be positive
about it like I gotta go on Jay Leno I
gotta like work with Katy Perry crazy I
gotta go to the Teen Choice Awards and
win a Teen Choice Award okay that's cool
it was cool and those were really like
crazy experiences to have
um but then at the same time like I
would like spend the rest of my day you
know just like reading what was going
down and that really sucked so holy [__]
I was pretty like disassociated oh you
found the Tosh for nothing there you go
it'd be nicely done
this is the internet archive apparently
it's not even online anymore wow
songwriting isn't for everyone of course
ironically because you didn't write the
song yeah
yeah which is funny because like this
isn't even that mean
yeah that is interesting isn't it oh
this is it it's a really small pose yeah
and then it had I think that was like a
the photo was of the video a link to a
video the joke they wrote is Rebecca
Black are you sure these are the lyrics
you want me to sing oh so they didn't
even they didn't even blame you for the
lyrics either I yeah I guess so I don't
even remember what this said producer uh
what are you talking about Rebecca Black
this part where I just kind of slowly
explained the ordering of the days of
the week that's the hook baby we
breaking it down for the kids they're
gonna know those days you know as an
original comment because they're
probably one of the first people to
comment on this it's not that bad no no
which is insane considering how far
people took it you know
um
and everyone can take what they will
with that idea but yeah shout out Mike
[__] whoever this guy is
let's see if who is this guy I'm curious
builds up for anything
yeah food and wine
okay so maybe he was a writer for Tosh
point now yeah I'd love to meet you Mike
maybe I can invite you to a show
dedicated to you yeah we we can you can
come up for the Friday remix yeah so
um
okay hold on one sec I gotta I'm gonna
thank our sponsors real fast or it's
just one sponsor just two minutes and
then we'll get back into it if you need
to use the bathroom or anything I
actually will yeah perfect so I'll do
this okay and then I'll see you in a
couple minutes thank you you too
thank you everybody to our new sponsor
today Eula yeah Kudos Kudos kudos to you
my friends to Kudos now you're already
getting the best deal with honey but now
you can get the most cash back with
kudos
yes thank you Kudos is a free smart
wallet that helps you get the most
rewards and benefits out of your credit
cards whenever you shop online I don't
know if you know people like this my dad
is one of these people growing up he'd
always be like Donna my mom you're using
the wrong card oh yes you've seen that
kind of thing you got you're supposed to
use this card not that card it's like oh
Jesus Christ who can keep track of this
stuff well with Kudos that's exactly
what they do
there's no more struggling to pick out
the red card for the purchase you just
shop like normal in that checkout Kudos
will show you the best card to use to
get you the most cash back
it's super easy to use
for example if you're at Target right
and uh you're buying something Kudos is
going to automatically recommend the
Chase Freedom Flex card because it
understands that at Target during that
quarter
you get the five percent cash back
because like with the chase cards it
rotates the category it rotates when you
get the cash back and it's like I don't
know how people are supposed to
triangulate that
you know what I mean but Kudos does it
for you and that's what that's what it's
all about isn't it
you don't have to think about it you
really don't you really don't uh and
that's not it actually my the best
feature of Kudos in my opinion
is that it reminds you of the secret
hidden credit card benefits
there are so many benefits to these
credit cards little nooks and Nanny
nooks and ninnies
like I just can't keep track of it and
and I don't have the energy to for
example if you're buying something at
Best Buy Kudo reminds you that using the
American Express gold offers you
purchase protection in case the new
airpods get stolen that's a benefit that
you would have never even known without
kudos
so it's actually pretty pretty nice it's
a really cool service it's free it's
super easy to use
and uh it's fun I think you guys are
really going to enjoy it it's a
no-brainer the average user unlocks 750
per year
and for a limited time only one lucky
person who signs up for Kudos will
receive a 50 dollar
gift card to Teddy fresh
I know
whoa I know that's cool kudos
so don't wait get kudos for free by
going to join kudos.com
h3tv links in the description that's
join kudos.com h3tv so they know that we
sent you shop Smarter with Kudos today
thank you thank you thank you with peace
and love to Kudos
love that all right thank you for that
excuse me
um
so I'm going back now
what is what is your what happens to
your life I mean overnight it gets a
million views when you go back to school
the next day or people starting to
realize or does it take time before
uh people fully understand around you
what's happening yeah I actually I think
I was out of town on like some school
trip
uh while it was all going down and so I
came back a few days later and so it had
been a few more days of like garnering
up attention and yeah the first day back
at school was pretty intense um
[Music]
which like looking back I'm like I don't
know
why this happened but like
at recess like every kid in the school
just like came up and like I guess had
questions or were like so equally
confused and like you know trying to I
don't know do something all being 12
year old so at first it wasn't like
super negative amongst your peers they
were mostly just curious what the heck
was going on I think so I think so
um and then
I mean honestly like from that point
because everything got so insane in like
my world and now there were all these
opportunities and obligations and you
know us trying to figure out what was
going on
um I didn't spend a lot of time at
school and so yeah I mean I started
doing like pretty poorly in my classes
and I was which like my parents being in
like medicine or obviously like insane
about you know their expectations
so I just yeah I started doing like
really poorly so they ended up taking me
out of school
and putting me in a homeschool to finish
the year they're only like a couple
months of the year left and
um yeah I mean I had definitely some
experiences with some kids in middle
school
um around the time it was like really
happening that were pretty shitty you
know just kids like
being stupid yeah you know saying little
things or singing the song and like oh
clearly not you know yeah positive way
which like I wasn't looking for people
to be like I love your song like you're
amazing like even that felt really weird
to me because I was like well I didn't
like this not this has this feels like
it has nothing to do with me and what I
wanted to do you know
so
um yeah yeah it was pretty much just
that that's interesting so you you did
homeschooling for a few months just
because two years actually a few years
yeah yeah
wow yeah was that almost a get away from
all the because I feel like it would
have been pretty hard for you to be
or maybe not hard but different for you
to be going through like high school and
middle school and stuff normally yeah in
the face of all that yeah it was I mean
because it just kind of like kept
ballooning in my world and like I got
pretty isolated from some of my friends
because obviously like I was in a really
weird headspace and tackling a bunch of
issues that I never dealt with before
and my friends were also probably like
hello like where the [__] are you and
what are you doing when I'm like up up
here you know for the first time and
working and
um trying to figure out what the hell is
happening
um so it was I I spent my first couple
years of high school doing like online
school
and yeah that was like probably the
lowest pit of
my like emotional yeah I can imagine
that that would be super isolating just
not being at home yeah school there and
then like I don't know do you even get
to socialize at that point
um I found some friends through like
Tumblr actually which was how I kind of
got connected to YouTube when I was like
16.
um I would just spend so much time
online and yeah I kind of lost like a
lot of my friends
um
from before
um lost a lot of connection with them
and just kind of did my own thing and
like my parents were obviously working
full-time my brother was in school so I
was alone for the majority of like being
14 and 15 other than you know coming up
and doing like at that time I was with a
manager that wanted me to go record new
music and you know do all this other
stupid
[__] honestly
um
and yeah it was really really a pretty
intense period
So when you say that was the lowest
point for you during that whole Arc like
um
as a how old were you at that point like
14 15 14 15. yeah
so just overall like feeling like
depressed and stuff like that I was so
depressed yeah I
at one point I went and saw a therapist
I was on antidepressants those did
nothing for me I mean I basically like
I think the thing that I felt at that
time was like whoa how did this just
happen where like I was you know less
than a couple years ago or less than a
year ago I was in a place where I was
like exploring and like so excited about
like what my future could be like late
like before Friday ever happened I was
like such a like happy little musical
theater kid like so excited and
passionate and like at that point I
literally felt like all of that had just
been like sucked out of me and now I I
don't even get to like explore that like
everyone has said like no
we don't want you here you don't belong
here you've actually ruined the sanctity
of this for all of us and like you know
all of the scathing like ruthless
reviews that were going on at the time
and then also like
dealing with now being a kid in the
industry where like everyone is
you know taking advantage of everything
you know that you want to do or think
that they should have you do so that
they can capitalize off of it like it's
really hard being a kid in a world where
like you're in an industry where yeah
everyone is only just trying to figure
out how they can
you know uh capitalize off of you do you
have any regrets kind of how it was
handled do you regret being homeschooled
or doing the video at the time did you
regret doing the video at all do you
wish you could just like go back in time
or oh I probably had huge regrets yeah
at the time yeah
um because I felt like I literally like
ruined my life
just pushed you to like mature overnight
because it's almost like before you were
this kid that could just be a kid and
not even like you said explore and
imagine what the future would be and
then like over and maybe not overnight
but over like a couple months yeah I
mean I think that all of a sudden now
like when once everything happened I
went my brain to cope was just like well
how do I make people not hate me
[__] you know so I like just tried to
you know cope with what what I thought
that could be and became you know I mean
like I not that any 13 year olds have a
sense of self but like that development
for me was so delayed because I the my
whole teenage Hood became like how do I
become
you know how do I find a group that like
identifies with me and like thinks I'm
like you know not this like bizarre like
weird dejected person
um
and which might sound like extreme to
people who are listening but it like
being a kid like you have no other
experience that doesn't sound extreme at
all to base your life no you're you're
the experience you went through was like
I mean nobody else your experience was
so unique that yeah I can imagine be
super hard to find anybody to relate
with you yeah I mean I was really
isolated and I spent a lot of my time
online like I that was what's so ironic
about the whole thing is like I spent so
much time isolated by myself trying to
find who I was that like that was when
like my love for like music and finding
the artists that like really resonated
with me and all of that really began
where it's like I was like you know just
like a little 13 year old like Justin
Bieber stand before like that's how I
feel like I started to find like some
semblances of like
real deep love for music was because
that was literally like all I had alone
in my room and Tumblr you know
um and yeah it was it was a an intense
were you guys ever actually ever able to
make any money from that whole
situation yeah yeah yeah I mean I own
the I own the master to the song okay I
didn't write it so I don't own the
publishing but I I so you own the
recording so anytime anybody used the
song
you get paid and then also does Arc get
paid for the PO the writing how does
that work can't talk about that oh you
can't talk about that okay yeah so
that's nice though that you at least
made a little bit of money from it and
you still are you still getting paid to
the for sometimes people use it and yeah
sometimes nice I mean I like have a lot
of other
stuff going on now luckily that it's not
my you know main source of Revenue but
it did I mean uh my like the way that it
works in the entertainment industry is
like when you're under age the way it's
supposed to work at least is like if
you're an underage person in the
industry you get a Coogan account set up
so when you turn 18 right 20 of
everything you've made gets opened up to
you and only you
um which my parents would have never
like touched that [__] but
um yeah so do you find it totally crazy
as someone who's Super Famous as a child
how on YouTube there's like no
protection laws for kids it's insane
isn't it so crazy it blows my mind every
time I know I know um yeah it's really
interesting to see like the world of
like the family vloggers and like the
kid influencers and I remember like
growing up and then becoming friends
with a lot of YouTubers and hearing
their stories about supporting their
families and I mean it's really like
yeah I I don't I wouldn't know how to go
about that but like it's It Seems like
by now there should be more in place so
when you when you say that there's an
account that needs to be made and the 20
like
that stuff doesn't happen on YouTube
families or I guess I don't know it's
supposed to in the entertainment
industry like it doesn't I don't think
because YouTube is crazy kind of
we're outside yeah it's outside the
thing but it's like whatever they choose
to do is what dude there's some kids
where they you there's some channels
where they're using their kids to make
like kids content or videos I mean the
biggest one I'm not saying they're doing
anything wrong I don't know but this one
Ryan's toys reviews do they make they
probably make hundreds of millions of
dollars because I think one time it was
like the most
earning Channel
yeah it's crazy it's still popping and
but
this kid Ryan who's even he's super
young when they started
and and you know I I I've never seen
anything bad about them so there's a
chance that they are responsible but I
hope so but I have so many other ones
it's just yeah yeah well and even now
like you see like these like kids on
Tick Tock right who are getting all
these brand deals and like I mean I'm
lucky that like my parents had at least
like some right guidance because they
had no [__] idea what to do like set
me up with like a company that like I'm
the soul you know I mean at least when I
turned 18 I became the sole owner of and
like
had my stuff protected yeah which every
person every child in the industry
should have yeah
um or like I mean even like labor laws
like yeah that was something that I
learned about when I even like would go
on like a late night set as a 13 year
old like you have to have a set teacher
you're only allowed to be like working
for a certain period of days yeah or
certain hours you know yeah working with
children is crazy strength and on
YouTube none of that [__] applies even
when I was on the Katy Perry video like
I was a co-star on her video for Last
Friday Night yeah and that was so strict
really like what was it like
um I mean I hated it at the time
obviously because I'm like why am I
doing school
um but I would like get to say I had to
have a set teacher with me at every
point but how long were you on set I was
on probably for like I don't know 12 14
hours I don't remember just one time a
couple days a couple days okay so this
teacher was with you the whole time they
have to be with you for a certain I
don't know the rules do they actually
teach you [__] or is it just like
bureaucracy
um I think because I was doing online
school I did like majority of she was
basically just supposed to like be there
to encourage me okay do it but probably
knowing me I was like on Twitter the
whole time
um so you know there could be more work
done and you know so what what other
things happened on set for you in like
the Katy Perry video
um that one was so rare I met Corey
Feldman
the king he was really very sweet
actually and like playing on his like
Nintendo DS the whole time
um I got Katy Perry was honestly like so
cool to me back in the day and so
just like get like sat down with me and
like talked to me several times
um just kind of gave me like some advice
um I Glee was like huge at the time I
got to meet them
um I don't remember what else there was
um
there was also something that I remember
kind of during that two-year period you
mentioned where
the original
uh music video was on Ark Music Factory
and then it moved to your personal
Channel
yes it got re-uploaded well I what I
have to imagine that there was some kind
of
issue there
I
I'm not really talk about it I mean I'm
sure if people like
can read about it so I'm okay there is
information about it so at that
situation whatever it was must have been
really intense too
yeah I mean at the time I was honestly
pretty shielded from anything other than
like my experience just being a kid
um and my parents wanted to keep it that
way of like you know anything messy or
so inappropriate for a 13 year old to be
involved in shouldn't be yeah
um but yeah it was it was like a very
confusing period wow yeah did your
parents feel like they made a mistake or
were they kind of feeling
hit from this whole situation too
probably you know I mean I think
yeah I I'm probably due to check in with
them again because it's like it's we've
all learned so much and kind of in
hindsight have
looked at it in a whole new lens and I
think that now like my parents are just
happy that I'm like doing something that
I love and able to take care of myself
and
um you know I do think that there's
pieces of that experience that
experience that made me who I am today
and put me where I am today but
yeah this comment is know the T that no
the t is confidential
also people are asked to keep asking me
if we've talked about Patrice she is
unable to discuss the trees yeah as it
relates to Friday are you able to talk
about Patrice as it relates to uh other
things I can't you can't okay I can't
respect yeah sorry to everyone no no no
no no Hey listen you gotta you gotta do
what you gotta do yeah yeah
we could say this for legal reasons you
can't discuss it can you say that or you
won't even go that far you can't say it
you can say that I can say that okay so
you know they're confirm nor deny what I
just said
okay
nor did I yeah there's some serious
business happening okay there's some
serious business yeah yeah serious
business yeah I wouldn't want to cross
Patrice either that's it scares the [__]
out of me he threatened me once really
yes or he was he was he actually had me
hiding he had me my house I was so
scared we literally did we did he made
he did some live stream wow he did like
a time count like counting backwards to
something
it was like a static live shot of a
bathroom curtain that kept moving and I
was like this is [__] it was
terrifying very scary it was scary I
would be scared too yeah we actually
like drove away from the house for
whatever is happening at that count wow
ending to not be there because we were
like wow scared I first discovered it I
was actually doing a show with post
Malone and someone's like yo you got to
pull up patrice's Channel and we were
watching it it was we were so scared and
then yeah and also he's [__] like
insanely like super human jacked and uh
he scares me that boy ain't right if
there's one thing I like don't [__] with
it's like any time I feel like my safety
is like I mean because people people be
out here being have you ever have you
ever felt unsafe during this whole
situation
um
yeah yeah not necessarily related to any
of the people that we've talked about
but like being a young woman online
attracts unfortunately naturally like
some really insane people and I've I've
had some experiences where people who
have inappropriately showed up at some
of my parents businesses have showed up
at my shows who have made some comments
or written some crazy emails I one time
when I was went back to public high
school had like a letter sent to my
school
um yeah like what what did the letter
say uh it was like no it was sent to the
the police department or I don't know I
got called out of school for it but
um just like some like gibberish remarks
about me and uh my family and you know
classic like Jesus nonsense stuff yeah
like serial killer [__] it was I mean
they ended up like tracking it down and
realizing it was like a you know like oh
they investigated it yeah I mean they
have to against like a child so that's
terrifying I mean I've had stuff like to
me happen as an adult yeah yeah I mean
there was there were death threats like
right after Friday we had a like a
security officer outside our house for
like a month so was that like a state
issued security officer was that like
private security I don't know yeah
it's a good question that's crazy yeah
people be out here doing some really
really insane things and saying some of
the same things yeah
you know it's just it's just kind of
interesting to think back like how angry
this video
I feel like that just must have [__]
with a young person's head like being
hated by so many people for literally no
reason really at the end of the day
you're just having fun didn't even mean
for it to go online yeah I mean it did
but for whatever reason
[Music]
I'm here yeah and I
ended up like
with some mix of you know
therapy and also I think probably trying
to
reason with whatever happened to me like
I for the past seven years since being
out here like have been so dedicated to
just doing something for myself and the
audience that I have had and built like
over the last few years especially and
you know
um I mean I think I I got to a point
where like how depressing would it be
if I literally like just did nothing
I've
discarded like all of these things I was
so passionate about you know as a kid
and like the joy that something brought
me as a kid I think that to me is the
coolest part about your journey and I
think it resonates with a lot of people
too like you would assume after going
through all that that you would just be
like I'm not I'm exiting this whole
thing but what's interesting and I think
really
um commendable is that you actually
stuck with it and continued to like I
mean the stuff you do now obviously is
is your own thing it sounds great I
thank you the um EP you dropped was
really good thank you and I'm definitely
gonna listen to your new album coming
out next month on the 8th the 9th
February 9th yes everybody
um go to Best Buy and open it on all the
tablets
Best Buy Apple Target yeah yeah yeah
yeah Apple's a good one there's lots of
open tablets there yeah but um it's
actually super commendable and awesome
that you stayed with it and turned it
into a positive experience for you yeah
I mean well I found a really like again
ironically like through this experience
I found such a passion at an outlet in
music and I really
you know as I started to get older and
look back on what had happened to me I
said like I to myself like I want to do
this right and I want to do this
in you know a way that like feels really
good to me and as somebody who as a
child and for like a long period of my
life had no control over
any piece of her life what happened to
her what was said about her what people
thought about her you know what she can
and can't say like I like
[__] like the one thing I'm gonna do is
like find something for myself and do it
with my like whole ass [__]
and then some and and again like I've
been so lucky
to find an audience that has like really
resonated with my journey and my music
and what I'm here to do and like
I'm I'm here to be a [__] pop star
like I've always known that ever since I
started
you know really trying to harness like
what this what my music could sound like
and what the Visions I had for myself
could look like like I'm
I I've just followed that and um yeah so
I hope people listen to the album
because they're going to on uh
you know February 9th February 9th y'all
better be opening and listening and
streaming 24 hours
so what was there a point during you
know your
um
this process of living through this
where you said I'm gonna I'm gonna try
making like uh
music for myself that other people would
maybe want to listen to as well
I think it was more so well it was a
you know really like complicated process
in terms of like I had to work backwards
basically and whereas like most I think
music artists would like write a few
songs and like those would kind of you
know just kind of live in the sanctity
of Their Own
worlds before anything maybe gains
traction like I had such a kick me sign
on my back and like so much I guess kind
of up against me that I needed to push
through
um just to get people to even like give
it any sense of legitimacy and so I I
spent a lot of years like writing a ton
of [__]
ton of bad stuff ton of like maybe okay
stuff and just trying to like really
understand to me like what if I had
something to say that has nothing to do
with like what I've been through like
what would but also everything to do
with what I've been through like what
would that look like and what would that
sound like and you know I just tried to
follow like the sounds and the things
that I felt so inclined towards and like
aligned with and tried to make music for
that so I think for a period it was like
let's make music that's digestible but
that actually didn't do anything for me
either it was like let me make music
that I get to at the end and I'm like
this is mine this is mine and nobody
else is and I don't really care if
people like it or not it's I know that
like this is a valid something because
it feels at least like me
um and when you which I never got to
have with Friday you know right when you
started posting it online again
a lot of people must have been like she
she can't be serious like she's coming
out trying to make music again or was
there a lot of people who were like okay
I can [__] with this or did you were you
not even in the comments I
I know
um I think that it's periodically like
changed over time and you know come like
a couple years ago when I started
putting out my last EP
Rebecca Black was here and I put out the
10-year Friday remix like that felt like
the moment where oh and I came out I
talked about my experience I think a
little bit more with Friday just like
honestly and what I was feeling and that
resonated with people I think more than
anything else
um and I just I have always followed
that like
or tried to follow I guess that line of
myself and just you know have like trust
that there'll be people that
see that yeah resonate well that's they
certainly do I mean you have like a
really
dedicated fans man they love you and in
the chat lots of love for you and just
next door and Teddy fresh do you have
like yeah like people were like oh cool
that really is like it's so
so cool for me and like means so much
for me to hear
um even if like one person I mean is
like definitely more than one person
yeah like when Ela reached out to me on
Instagram I was like
[Music]
um well somebody yeah that wasn't always
the case some of you guys on the crew
were fans who were like yo you should
check out Rebecca Black yeah Olivia
music I love your new music oh and Ian
by the way is the culture is the Taste
maker here which one are you talking
about Ian that you love
uh well your song with the Slater wow
favorite tracks uh that year I love that
song dude that's huge
he barely even talks
that means a lot wow yeah no I mean it
really it means so much that people are
like listening and like vibing and like
I did my first headlines last year in us
and in Europe and like I got to sell out
so many of those shows I got to go to
Australia and play shows and like Friday
is a [__] Bop live can you ever do
that live like how do you I always do it
live no way actually I won't confirm or
deny that you'll have to come to the
show
so you hit it like the old school Friday
no no
I did a remix uh in 2021. can you play
the old school Friday yeah you can yeah
yeah yeah okay just curious
um but uh I did a remix that was
produced by Dylan Brady of 100 guests
and that had Doreen Electra Big Frida
303 on it we did a whole video yeah
how'd you get that together how do you
get in the process of getting all those
it was psychotic I mean I had the idea
for so long and it was basically just a
matter of like tracking people down and
being like
this would be so [__] cool if you did
this will you do it and like people like
Dorian and Dylan I like become a little
bit friends with through working
together meeting each other and
um yeah everyone was just like psyched
about it that's so cool yeah yeah the
way you've handled like owning it has
been perfect for sure like putting out
the remix and showing that you kind of
like have a new creative spin on it and
in a way it's kind of like launching
your new Direction at the same time but
also saying like yeah this is also my my
past yeah not trying to like run away
from it and making that remix wasn't
about like and now I'm gonna show you
guys that this is actually a good song
it was like let me take this thing that
I had no control of right and do
something absolutely batshit with it and
in a way that like fits all of my
creative like you know know I don't know
things and and pieces and Inspirations
that I love and also like there's so
many tributes to that era like there's
the troll memes in there there's like
all these like really fun things that I
was I was stoked to be able to include
in that as like this is a crazy moment
you know looking at how the internet has
even changed over the past 10 years and
now you have artists like that almost
make cringe like really cool and that's
been a really cool thing to see just as
like a
Watcher of
how pop culture I think what's
interesting too kind of about your path
is that a lot of the people who you know
what I was thinking Friday's a lot like
9 11.
and let me tell you what okay let me
tell you why
it's because everybody remembers where
they were I remember where I was in my
life
I remember it might even be more 911
than 9 11 if I mean oh my God okay I was
in Israel okay and you know it was like
such a huge moment but then I I just had
to jump in and say I I remember exactly
yeah I actually do wow I was in college
I was in a set building class and a
friend of mine walked up to me and was
like hey you've seen this and yeah
you're right everybody's saying same see
what's insane is like my girlfriend that
I've been dating for the last year
was so unaware of Friday she lived in
Paris at the time wow and like Paris
Vibes
but she was like so unaware of anything
that had happened and like knew of my
name because we had found mutual friends
and all that but yeah I unfortunately
like came to a point where I was like I
feel like I have to make you watch like
get the whole picture of what's going on
here was it kind of nice I guess that
she doesn't no I don't really care I
mean I like I've as long as you're not
like a dick to me about it I like you
know it's it is what it is yeah so
but my point I guess was that we all
remember where we were that is really
true I was working yeah this is before I
had a career before I even wanted to be
on YouTube or make a YouTube or even
kind of when I was still learning about
what YouTube was right that was when
Friday hit
and um I think a lot of the people
who were younger at that time and saw
that go down and participated in all
this Friday Mania and now seeing you
grown up and hearing about your
experience now I feel like a lot of
people have
have like are now rooting for you and
and wanting to support you as a result
of realizing how [__] up that
situation was and then coming out and
seeing that you're you weren't like
defeated by that I think a lot of people
uh want to support that myself included
you know what I mean well thank you yeah
I mean that's really sweet and
everyone's had a lot of time to mature
and then realize oh that was so crazy
and [__] well shit's gotten like
worse in the world I mean [__] was
probably really bad in 2011 too but like
there's bigger
fish to fry but then again I still see
it like all the time the internet
which even this was the case when I was
a kid is I would like some of the tweets
I remember so specifically that I would
get that were like the grossest like
meanest thing like what if you remember
them oh just stuff that was like you
should kill yourself you ugly [__] like
yeah we're coming from people who had
like I'm an anti-bullying advocate in
their bio on Twitter and I still see
that [__] all over the place with like
these young girls and kids who get
online and are just like I mean I have I
have an almost eight-year-old sister and
like I see her on Tick Tock every day
just like using it like watching [__]
and I'm like
please please like stay like safe and
pure and like all of that because people
are ruthless still you know
um well what's your advice to kids as
someone who's been through probably the
most crazy experience on social media
how do you survive that like how do you
keep saying through all that
um well if you're dealing I mean I guess
my advice would more so be to like
adults than to kids because to me kids
like should not be the ones in charge of
like
you know not getting bad comments or
hate or given towards them are
inappropriate comments if you're a kid
and like you're dealing with
with things that feel
really difficult like you shouldn't be
that wasn't the most eloquent way to say
that but like if if you're getting
hateful comments online or things said
about you like one that's not just
something that you have to deal with as
like a kid or that you deserve to deal
with
you deserve to be able to have like a
creative output and a creative outlet
and and to be safe
um
you know you don't have to earn that as
a child I think more so my advice would
be to parents of like I see so many
parents nowadays kind of like their
their big way of dealing with
with the internet with their kids is
like don't look at it like you're not
allowed to have it and like you're not
allowed to do any of this and I don't no
no which I understand but
kids
are going to find their way on it like I
wish I saw more parents like actually
taking the time to like be just aware of
like what even like actually Tick Tock
is or like what actually goes down or
like talk to your kid like in a way
that's not judgmental or like
condescending about what they're
watching or in taking just be aware so
that your kid feels like they can come
to you if something goes wrong you know
that was always like
the thing that really helped me was at
least I could come to my parents and
like and my mom specifically and just be
like
I am so confused and lost and you know
she could just support me through that
and like
we have two young boys yeah it's
actually something I've always been
wondering or I've been thinking about a
lot as they get older and the social
media thing becomes inevitable yeah
but I think that's really good advice
because it's like abstinence only
education I mean you can't you're not
going to keep them off yeah and and I
was a kid in a situation where my dad
just didn't let me do anything really
like just nothing so
I hated that you know so I know how that
threw up too really and that's nice
well did like did you go and find it
elsewhere anyway or no yes I did but but
if not at that moment then you do it
later which is also like just annoying
because you don't get to do it with your
friends when they're doing it well I'm
like it's just isolating yeah and it's
so I don't know I just think it's really
backwards and then again I'm not a
parent so take what I'm saying with a
grain of salt but like
I to see any like way of progress moving
in terms of like well we can't allow the
children to be a part of this because
it's the children that are online that
are the problem no it's the
inappropriate people that are online and
the hateful people or the people who use
the internet as like some weird
Anonymous Outlet to say [__] to get
through their own life like that's the
issue so why why aren't we doing
something about that I think that's the
best advice if a parent can like go
spend time on the app see what it is and
creating Like An Open Door judgmental
door
yeah it's definitely I think the best uh
yeah the best I don't know we're all
also like watching this go down all
right who knows and by the way huge dub
for you recently on Andrew Tate wow that
was [__] awesome it was so good thank
you um
and so true by the way
you tweeted it's just simply facts I
mean I said nothing but bags so good
um you said I was 13 this man was 36 and
this song
man who made this and put it online
it's just embarrassing yeah well he's in
jail so
spend a little time all you gotta do is
ask me oh my God
it like actually like oh my God it gives
me a hard time even watching it you know
what you know what the only thing
missing is a verse by Patrice
that would crush this
dude I still remember patrice's verse I
think
I mean it's an iconic verse it's so
iconic it's just so bizarre it's just so
[__] bizarre
my God yeah no RB Rebecca Black was an
iconic yes
at least she typed you up you know I
mean
it's true
in that moment he hyped me up yeah do
you feel like it's and like
always present in your life even today
because you're growing up and still
maturing
I don't know if it's almost like a
traumatic experience where sometimes it
takes like a long time it can take years
to unpack really what happened to you in
a way like looking at it in an adult's
eye instead of your because your memory
is like in a kid's point of view
looking at it now as an adult is it
still like with you all the time kind of
like I mean I think my perspective has
changed every year like as I grow older
I have new understanding because also
like there were so many pieces of what
went down like you said I was a kid like
I was barely even involved in it and so
now as a 25 year old I learn like oh wow
I didn't even realize that happened or I
didn't even realize this went down and
um
yeah I mean it's it definitely stays
with me I mean clearly here I am like
talking about it
[Music]
um
but I've done a lot of where I mean I
did like years of intense therapy
I've be you know I I think I've become a
lot more comfortable
um coming to peace with with that and
like and again like in my world like
with my audience like Friday is like
whatever you know yeah so that's what I
care about is like my new [__] like
everything that my like fans are so
[__] cool to me about like nobody
really gives a [__] about Friday I'm not
being like yeah it's a gay icon moment
you know and like we all sing to it at
the show and we're like this is crazy
you know
um and that that is like the really has
been the the biggest like
accomplishment for me and also I still
know is like a huge accomplishment for
me if I want to do this is like so many
people I still see [__] every now and
again of like people saying like stupid
2011 era jokes does it bother you or not
not anymore I I mean I just know it'll
exist but like I know that like I'm in a
pivotal moment for myself that like as a
as an artist and like as somebody who is
like here to do this as just as much of
a pop star as like any of the other
girls out there right now or people pop
people
um
you know I have I still am like I have I
want people to listen to the album I
want people to see the show I want
people to take me you know not just as
like oh this is good for the Friday girl
but like this is good you know or like
just make an opinion on it separate a
Friday because like that's so so old
nothing makes you look like more [__]
cringe online than like saying like some
weird like oh death battle between
Justin Bieber Rebecca Black like or if
like Rebecca Black and whoever were in a
house fire would you like get a drink or
like go get a coffee like nothing makes
you look worse I think I may not you
know people are still saying stuff like
that I can't either but they do okay
well so but you know um
people were asking me to pull this up
just to go back for a minute
this is the clip we were live on the
podcast we were with post Malone oh oh
wow and then somebody sent us this link
and they're like yo Patrice is streaming
and he has your name in the title
curtain
um do you have to turn this off we
thought I thought that it was like we
thought it was an image and then we
realized there was someone behind
so creepy dude
oh my God very large countdown yeah
I know look how skinny I am holy [__]
dude what the hell holy [__] what the
[__] you know what's crazy is I thought
I was kind of fat back then I guess I
was maybe but don't let the dysmorphia
get to you we all now I'm fat then I was
well you're not really fat anymore I
mean yeah it's been losing a lot of ways
Elis said I have those I'm as big as
Nick ocado like six months stop it you
don't have to comment on that but I'm
just letting you know
I didn't even see the full body it's
based on like I go yeah you think I look
like Nick said you're in the same Realm
then
what do I do it wasn't that far no Dan
no I didn't Dan well that was what Colin
that was a waking up moment for me God
I'm in the same realm as Nicki
but we were only looking at like from
here up I didn't even know how further
and make me feel better you're just
you're just morbidly I was like I don't
know
because you
look like Jabba the Hutt from the Belly
Up only
beautiful legs strong legs
anyway here
is that with like a kid's head and then
what like what do you do that yeah I'll
find out later I'll find out later
we were looking at it yeah I don't know
it's really weird it was really creepy
wow that was a while ago [__] that's
crazy young post too yeah yeah he was
yeah he was a young and then wow
um
well listen
it's all good things happening uh for
Rebecca Black
and um I'm happy for you and I'm glad
people are
are taking notice
especially I'm glad that everyone's
adding to their calendar that let her
burn Rebecca's full-length debut album
is coming out February 9th
[Music]
coming out everywhere
there's singles out now you can listen
singles are out right now
look at you Bob stick to my stomach Bop
stick to my stomach that's the one you
love Yeah Olivia's room one of my
favorites I supposing I probably can't
play it
I don't know probably have a label right
oh no I'm independent you are yeah oh
[__] we might actually be able to listen
to it maybe just couldn't you someone
just re-upload it what we could Chester
real fast yeah that'd be cute
congratulations for being independent
okay I love that you know it's it's
really like it's a it's a position that
like I really love but it's also
definitely a struggle you know what's
the difference at the end of the day
well I mean the industry's changing so
much so major labels positions have
definitely shifted in terms of like what
levels their importance holds but I
think there's benefits to labels in
terms of like radios I'm pretty sure are
like basically owned by labels you want
anything no radio I mean you'd be
surprised people do still but like in
terms of of me and like my goals like my
having the creative control and like the
just ability to like literally make
every decision with me and like my core
team that I like really trust
um that's super sick yeah you know in
this rollout we've been able to do
exactly how we wanted financially that's
got to be a lot better for you too right
well better and a lot harder I mean
everything is like coming out my bank
account if we can't do something it's
because the bank account's not you know
bad enough yet not fast it will be yet
but it's going to stream the album
pre-order the vinyl come to the show
maybe one day we'll get there we're
gonna we're gonna we need a fat [__]
Rebecca Black you're getting there
already there yeah guys it's happening
it is happening it's all happening and
guys once again
uh the website is
just rebeccablack.com yeah yeah and you
can get tickets
you get tickets you can get merch let's
see what's the tournament okay you're in
Dublin yeah UK yep blah blascal Lasko
Glasgow Glasgow love Glasgow people are
crazy in Glasgow that's pretty cool
you're doing like a UK tour is that do
you have a lot of fans in that side I do
I'm actually playing my biggest headline
in London for like a thousand people yo
that's awesome pretty close to selling
out which one is that uh London February
10th it's actually the album really show
which is exciting yo yo everyone you
have on your team how many people yeah
um it's me my manager I've got a
publicist
um you know some people who work with
both of them
um and like as far as like I have an
attorney you know as far as that that's
like kind of my core team
um
I collaborate with a bunch of different
directors and you know artists and stuff
like that but yeah we're
as far as Barbie Friday over here just
working running it as like a business
does it all come to you decisions
coordination of things
um I mean at the end of the day
anything has to like get approved by me
but I I mean I think I'm like I'm at a
place now growing up as like a kid
understanding the industry there was
definitely a huge period of like I had
no idea what the [__] was going on
um
but I I think like it's pretty it's
pretty even Keel but at the same time
like nobody can really do anything
without
my approval I guess right you know
that's nice to have that control
honestly it's a lot more work but it's
important it's taught me a lot
especially as you are growing your
career you know what I mean yeah they'll
probably come a point where you can't be
involved in everything but yeah no it's
definitely I mean it's stressful but
it's taught me so much about you you
know
kind of like
really how much leadership has been
especially with my experience and like
my own trauma around that like
it's been so important for me in finding
confidence in what I do so we got
claimed I wonder who got us let's see
um maybe it's like the distro company
they just automatically let me see
they're gonna pull up the details
it's complicated you know those mother
efforts those dis is that how you do it
distro kid uh not distro kid but I've
got like a distribution yeah situation
um one of those
I did I have been a long time CD Baby
Queen she's a baby you know about CD
baby that's the one like this real kid
right kind of yeah I mean I still be
using CD Baby no yeah so
um
let's basically we're going to
move on to some other stuff and I'm not
sure you're welcome to join us well does
anyone have any questions
anyone else you guys have any questions
for for Mrs uh I don't know if you guys
do that
yeah I can take kids I'm so curious what
people are saying questions yeah you
guys have any questions well the first
of all I'll tell you the chat loves you
Rebecca whack but whack like w do you
know that what that that doesn't really
work with the whack yeah oh like like
that doesn't sound good whack though no
yeah actually nobody's saying that I
just made it Dash Go audio B oh who are
these people uh it's just the people
that distribute my music that's like an
independent sorry if we if we had time
we could have we could have sorted this
no it's all good it's so good but y'all
go listen for Christ's sake all right
let's see I'm gonna field some questions
it takes like a short second to uh catch
up there's like a little bit of a delay
how was working with bbno oh baby no
money baby no money
um that was so fun that was so cool that
was like so Random he dm'd me and was
just like hey I have a verse
um you want to be on the song and uh he
sent it to me and it was really good and
so we did a song together last year
called or 2021 called yoga
everybody's asking for Pride minute I
don't know if that do you guys think
that's appropriate for me to do right
now for what I do this thing where we do
a pride minute I don't know if you know
who Jordan Peterson is
but he during pride month he said what's
the deal with pride month months they
don't need a whole month really a month
they should get a day at best and so I
said well we need actually to have a
pride minute we need to shrink it down
as much as possible
so we have one minute to celebrate and
then at the end of it we tell people to
basically get back in the closet and to
be ashamed that's so cool that you got
that yeah yeah but we give them one
minute to celebrate in honor of Jordan
one minute a year one minute actually we
do a lot of minutes but one minute a
year is what he wanted
and so we kind of just do a little goof
on that okay you really want to do it
well if you do enough minutes it adds up
that would be more than a month I could
see it being beneficial but if that's if
that's but are you people are saying are
you gonna do the second part though
we'll see we'll feel the vibe and then I
do I cosplay is like uh We're not gonna
do any like not slay Geisha yeah no
we're still we are Pros we are slaves it
is all every day we're Pride it is all a
parody but yeah it's all very perfect
then I I cosplay as like a fire and
brimstone preacher who says that you
know uh when two dudes kiss there's a
hurricane and
forward and stuff so people want it and
I don't know if I didn't want to put you
in that position but it is all parody
and we we have a lot of uh gay kings and
queens and trans people in our audience
we love that yeah the gays are are they
want it though so I guess we can do it
and then you can have you ever been out
in weho before or like been out like
have y'all ever like
been out on the scene
that's one of my favorite things to do
is like take straight people to like gay
clubs no I would love I don't do I don't
go to any clubs well yeah we don't
really go out at all that's fair
actually yeah I I haven't I would love
to work well Akbar great place
what does that mean they basically it's
like a monthly party
um a monthly club night that is like
dedicated to like whatever the
astrological sign is oh that's fun so
it's supposed to be like I don't know
what we're in right now Aquarius I don't
know but like it'll be like this the
Aquarius month you're supposed to be
able to like go and like meet aquariuses
that might do some themed [__] that's
fun I've heard the gay bars are fun I've
got two boys I don't have any time I
don't do any bars wow I prefer not to
leave the house personally I mean that's
fair I'm saying you know honestly this
is my preference all right you guys
really want me to do good Pride minute I
mean do you guys
because I was briefly number one on
wikiFeet men until wow
I dominated wikiFeet so hard they just
they removed wikiFeet men rating system
because wow crushing yeah so do you put
do you like offer a lot of feet content
that was so crazy to me or like the ways
that people get like I there was this
era where I kept getting tagged and
stuff that was like the the uh the giant
women thing there's like a thing of like
gigantress is that what they call it
where it's like they'll like edit these
photos of of women that are like giants
like in the city so you'll be like
almost like Godzilla okay but it'll just
be photo of you like from your Instagram
I think so really yeah but I'm kind of
with it yeah I mean can you guys send me
a picture of that I would love I'd love
to see it well like yeah all of that
stuff is really fun do you want to see
your prolapse
what
oh God we have kind of this tradition of
uh maybe not really a tradition it is
kind of you remember how we met Del he
posted that Tick Tock with the prolapse
did you see that cover the whole thing
no okay no I do I did I was on America's
Got Talent one time though you were you
were yeah as like a performer like a
guest how long ago a guest performance
wow that's a bad performance really how
long ago was it it was like 2011. okay
so yeah yeah it's been a while yeah it
was rough yes it's this Vibe that's not
I don't know if that's oh it's not yeah
yeah they'll take like a photo of you
and then they put you on these and I
just think it's so epic I've never seen
this before no I love it is this like a
Tumblr thing where do you think I just
get tagged in them on like Twitter and
stuff they do it a view yeah they'll
take one of my photos but it's not
animated it's like just simply like can
we crop on deviantART which deviantART
does seem like the place where you you'd
find so she's got a controller too I
like how specific
do you mind if I pull up one of you I
think it's epic yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
let's see I'm like I'm you know oh well
here here's one that's not you but wow
dude this is interesting I didn't know
about this yeah yeah giantess giant test
that's what they're called I think it's
so
well I wonder what's the fan is so
honored to be included like all the
things that people have like cropped me
into over the years
this is do they want to get like stomped
by you do they not get eaten by you I
don't know just I think giant test
Community speak up it's like they look
at you as like this super powerful yeah
yeah
uh here okay yes just chilling just
chilling in Cedar Rapids I love it
oh wow defeat bro oh my God you're like
I've got you giving that out for free I
guess I won
this must have been before I really knew
yeah
same Vibe today you got to be careful
with the feed on the internet today man
people go crazy for that I know well
yeah no no now the feet the feet are
being saved for like we'll find a moment
yeah yeah you know good good here's more
of this stuff it's really fascinating
here you are there I am
just walking damn you're a bastard
that's the biggest it's a really good
one I like what they added holy [__]
you're like and there's like actually
man yeah there's destruction you're like
destroying the land I like the realism
of that that is one of the bigger ones
I've seen very large dude you're like a
mild size Twitter size Twitter a certain
Sparkle told me it wasn't Friday when I
posted the last Rebecca Black collage
well now it's Friday and those boots do
be stomping oh [__] sorry that's all I
guess I need to turn I have some
questions from the audience if you want
to feel some sure sure all right let's
take a look here I just now my the
Discord just full of big ass pictures of
you
here let me pull actually I got one more
I want to look at oh my God this is
actually pretty graphic you guys this
page is maybe not safe okay
all right here let's say
um here I'm gonna resend them since they
got buried
okay thank you if you could go back in
time would you change anything about
your experience or what would you tell
yourself
um
I don't think I would change
it I mean
the whole other like like mess of
possibilities and I do think that
through that experience I
again I learned certain things about
myself I gained like a certain amount of
empathy for you know people with similar
experiences and all of that that like
definitely has shaped me hopefully for
the better so
I don't think I would change anything
um and also like I don't think that and
this has been something I've come to
recently like I don't think I did
anything wrong no which I think was
something I had to take a long time to
Grapple with you felt did you feel
guilty through it all like of course I
felt like an idiot so interesting you
know what did you feel guilty for just
making it just being there being there
for [__] it up for doing something
stupid like it's you know like that kind
of feeling of like you know when you
pick out like a pair of shoes and you're
like oh this is cool I like these and
someone's like what are those [__]
ugly I mean I hope nobody does this but
like you know what are those yeah Vibes
um I had a lot of Shame is what it was
um but if I guess if I could go back in
time I mean I guess that'd be like one
of the things I would tell myself it was
like there is no need to have shame
around this and that's something that as
a 13 year old you're not going to
understand for a long time but like you
did nothing wrong and like you have
nothing to feel sorry about or like
ashamed about or guilty about
um yeah because that was probably the
most hurtful part or the most
destructive part was a shame was going
out hard for you like going out to a
restaurant going on vacation whatever
I'm sure y'all went out do people
recognize you a lot out yeah like ever
it just depends you know
um I like now I've felt that more and
back in the day it was like I definitely
felt afraid of it
um I'd had some experiences of people
who would like spot me in a mall and be
like you know saying crazy [__] from
across the room or something like
heckling you yeah yeah
um and I had like like high school was
pretty rough when I went back into
public high school but
um but yeah yeah
chill let's see um
do you
yell are so wild all right here I'll
just pull it up what's your thoughts on
this this is a new artist breaking
through maybe a clever a collaboration
your guys's future loving already
[Music]
cheers
well this is not even real right this is
that thing it's the face filter right
that's not his real face yeah that's
what I keep saying yeah for sure so hit
me with something legitimate and then we
can we can't find anything
I mean great Lighting on his face dude
fantastic not a poor Insight I love that
you know he's got a vocal tone is there
a dream collab
for you in mind
um oh my gosh there's so many people I
would love to work with
uh I would love to work with there's so
many people in my field I feel like like
the Charlie xcx's I get that like ass
all the time she's so cool I love her
love I mean
would love to like
have like some I don't know like a
pitbull collab
okay yeah Mr worldwide Mr worldwide whoa
sir
um would you settle for an Oliver tree
[Laughter]
um maybe maybe I could probably I could
probably put in a word there's
definitely been some like communication
see I'm not sure I think it would be
good for him I'm not sure that would be
good for your career to yeah we'll have
to see it
doesn't have a great reputation and his
music isn't that good wow
no he's my he's my buddy
cool
um I mean there's a lot of like really
cool I think artists out there that I
don't know whether they're more up and
coming and stuff like that I love to
okay work with yeah um do you have any
bad celebrity encounters ooh
uh big ones I know you had a good one
with Katy Perry I had a good one with
Katie bat I've honestly been pretty
fortunate to like have cool experiences
[Music]
um
bad celebrity encounters I'm trying to
think I mean
I think probably one of the worst
moments of my life was like I
went to some award show and like Justin
Bieber had a snake there and I was a
huge like I was such a big fan of this
guy like I literally talked about it in
interviews I had like a cut out and he
walked by me and he just like bumped
into me with a snake and it was so
unintentional on his part like he
literally didn't even know I existed but
I there was nothing more like
hurtful as like a fan to just like be
like
okay he's shoulder never gonna be yeah
we were just like in a tight space and
he like fully unintentionally shoulder
bumped me and I was just like damn I'm
never gonna be that girl I'm never gonna
be one less lonely girl I really crushed
you yeah he had a snake on him yeah yeah
he brought a snake to an award show a
little bit pull that up Pinterest yeah
um but otherwise like I'm trying to
think I think I've been pretty chill
with like decent experiences yeah
um everyone's a little weird do you oh
you know what you're it's funny you were
saying um that you're a fan of Shane and
all this stuff is it kind of weird how
like
all that's developed like Shane garlic
brutally canceled man yeah yeah I mean
I've talked about that a little bit and
like it was interesting when
wow this is us we're half underground we
are yeah just popping up you know in the
middle of La where are we we're like
by the 405 okay no I see the Capitol
building right there I think you're in
Hollywood oh wow okay yeah this is my
neighborhood wow I love that that's epic
yeah thanks crushing the Palladium
but uh yeah I've talked about the Shane
stuff a little bit I mean when all of
that came up I mean I don't even know if
I have a lot to say on at this point
yeah as a fan
said it I mean I he was we did some like
collabs and he had me like on his
podcast when I was younger and he was
very I mean in our like interactions
very nice to me but looking back there
were definitely obviously a lot of like
really inappropriate bits that he would
use about me and my body and really yeah
yeah that was his whole shtick I guess
looking back yeah yeah and I know that
like you know for whatever reason it was
for shock or whatever I don't know if
that excuses it but I haven't really
talked to him
sense all that stuff went down I mean
that was one of those things that like
looking back I had such a different
lens
um that when I was like can I pull this
up does this bother you you got this you
got the Shanaynay treatment I got the
Shanaynay treatment this is like uh the
black face character isn't it it's not
the best yeah but
um yeah can I watch this
if you want you don't want to watch it I
mean there's just nothing like really I
think positive about like you know
there's like some really bad jokes in
there that I'm like uncomfortably
laughing about because I don't know what
to do you can't take anything you know
for this one no but you know I mean as
like the internet does like there were
definitely some people who were like why
were you involved with this I'm like I
didn't know the script oh my God you
know everybody loves Shane until like
all of a sudden everybody didn't uh it's
been you know it's you just hope that
people I mean
are taking account I really haven't
talked to him but I hope he's taking
accountability
yeah oh wow yeah there's the thing thank
you yeah it's not your fault thank you
anyway I can't believe these are still
like up well these are all re-uploaded
it looks like yeah my date the black
yeah y'all did a lot of content actually
I mean he used me for a lot of content
dude yeah
[Laughter]
um did they get a lot of views his
content with you yeah yeah I think it
was like this was like a you know Heyday
moment for him probably
um you know what was were people being
nice at least at that time where you
were more in on the joke
I don't know no I don't know it was
pretty brutal the first few years of
just like I mean there were always
people who had my back for sure
um but yeah pretty rough
I see well
Shane is uh
I wonder if you were thinking back on
that though in retrospect because he got
busted like for being super gross and
inappropriate with really young kids I
guess that made you think back to me
like oh God damn that was kind of weird
I mean again like in my interactions I
never felt unsafe
um but I also like to give some context
was so at that point used to being the
butt of every joke and like having so
many I mean there have been people ever
since I was 13 being like can't wait
till she turns 18. oh that's so gross so
I think my like relationship with it at
the time was just like oh this is like
another Moment Like laugh it off be cool
yeah don't be you know because also like
the internet again hasn't always been so
kind so what's it like to get to see
that kind of comment as a young person
like I can't wait till she's 18. it was
so vile gusting I mean
I definitely had a hard time
understanding like my relationship with
sexuality and sexuality and
um obviously like
realizing like my queerness and all that
was a separate thing but like for so
long I think I struggled with
with confidently portraying that in a
way that felt like my own but like on
this album there's some songs that are
like super sexy and like really like
coming from my own just like ideas and
experience and I'm really excited to
share that because that has been a part
of my life I'm 25 you know I've been
like out here living my life dating
people and
um and that's I just haven't even really
realized until this recent era that like
I haven't ever shared that so much
because I've been kind of that's felt
like something
I was almost afraid to for so long when
did you
um come out I guess uh
I think it's been almost three years
three years yeah did you did you know
that you were gay for a long time or was
it kind of uh a confusing thing that you
learned about yourself
um
it was kind of something I learned when
I was I think I was around 20. and I all
of a sudden was like
what is happening like why am I so
enamored with this person I started
having relationships and all that and
um
yeah it all kind of like fell in my in
in front of me
um but then looking back I'm you know it
becomes a lot easier to be like oh okay
that like wasn't something that you just
like wanted to be your friend really
badly when you were 11 you know but I
mean like I'm yeah I'm kind of and
I kind of have felt very comfortable
like living my life in terms I just I
don't know I just find someone I fall
really in love with them and was it hard
for you coming out of the closet or or
was it kind of uh
an easy thing to do with your family and
everything you've been through
um overall it was pretty positive I mean
I'm from Orange County which is like not
the most liberal place in the world
considered like Mega County it's yeah
it's pretty rough
um and I mean I've grown up in L.A like
I've identified myself very far away
from that for a very long time but there
were like not always super positive
experiences but now I'm at a place where
like yeah I mean I love having my like
girlfriend around my family I love you
know
I I'm super lucky to like when I came
out online was at a time where like it's
so much more
accepting and welcoming because of you
know the experiences that people have
had and the things that people have
fought for in the past so it's been
great and like it's something a lot of
me and my audience really share like a
lot of like the lgbtq plus Community
really backed me long before anyone else
did so that's been really and how long
have you been dating your partner almost
a year oh that's nice that's so great
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
um
you wanna
people are getting my head we have so
many gay memes like Pro gay memes
slay yeah but like a programming Zach
we yes
loving this Pete Davidson cut out in the
corner
yeah Olivia is obsessed with uh with him
and for are you still feeling Pete
Davidson or is that waned at all are you
still full
throttle
you're a focus
okay it was like some right before that
Andrew Tate thing there was some ex like
2023 uh I don't know predictions thing
that was like Rebecca and Pete spotted
oh God yeah yeah you did see that but
that's got to be pretty low right I mean
considering
but we got jealous Pete Davidson you
never know you'd make an exception for
Pete potentially
um I mean I'm like so happy in my
relationship but and I do know some
people who have dated him but yeah I
don't know I don't know okay there it is
he's on his own bad yeah he's on his own
Vibe yeah
all right guys stop with the pride
minute it's not happening I felt muted
um it's a good thing trust me right I
just I know it sounds weird
what is this what oh this is the Pete
Davidson moment oh
wow this photo of me that photo's so
nice don't you agree
sure yeah you don't like it it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine Rebecca
Vlog
Pete David said what the [__] is that
true you want to wait
so this tweet went like was going around
and then I saw it and I thought it was
funny and so I was actually with my
girlfriend and I was like oh I should
tweet about this and I was like what
should I say and she was like well you
should say like well if P if Pete lets
me wear a strap on oh sure that's
awesome and then that literally
resonated with that you keep having like
big Twitter moments I do love Twitter
yeah you guys need to go follow
um Rebecca blacks dropping Banger after
Banger it's so true
by the way album cover is awesome thank
you very very ninth we mentioned that
yep February 9th oh there's you could
play this I'm sure
[Music]
do you practice dancing a lot uh yeah I
worked for the choreographer for this
video
you're probably gonna get claimed
unfortunately yeah well there you got to
hear some of it so
it sounds great it's kind of retro in a
way yeah yeah there's a lot of 80s
influence yeah yeah um which I love so
much
um yeah this is this is one of my
favorites on the album excited people
this is the one that uh what's this one
called stick to my stomach yeah yeah
bun yeah
so well there we go I'm very excited for
what you know is in store for you thank
you very happy for you and uh your story
is incredible you're gonna have to write
a book someday or something yeah
documentary something I don't know
yeah but uh you know what I think you're
gonna you're gonna go there you're on
your way to pop stardom thank you well
thanks for having me on yeah I mean what
a full circle for me really for me for
me too listen I'd be spending a lot of
time on YouTube yeah yeah that's awesome
well
this tour have a great time
rebeccablack.com everybody set your
calendar it's February 9th now you're a
friend of the show so everybody's got a
ride for you well any of my Dubliners
I'm gonna be there this Saturday this
Saturday wow get in there y'all yeah
come to the show it's fun show
[Music]
um awesome well thank you so much
um you do you want to do you want to
hang out or you can we can go I don't
want to kick you off necessarily you
know what I mean I can kick my
thanks for watching yeah we're just
going to talk about it we're going to
continue well how long we've been going
Dan
uh two hours wow oh wow two hours two
hours holy [__] oh yeah I think you have
to go okay I think your manager told us
you have a out all right well I'll let
him be the one that
um
usually we just talk [__] on a bunch of
people so people don't want to be
associated with that like we're gonna
make fun of Mr Beast right now that's
like career suicide you definitely don't
want to be involved in that all right
yeah I will I haven't had a beast Burger
yet I will go horrible now
actually I wanna I'll say goodbye if you
guys want to just uh hang around for a
minute we'll come back we'll talk about
a few things for like a do another hour
and then we'll
end it yeah so amazing uh you guys just
take the reins for a minute so I can say
goodbye will do all right thank you for
coming on Rebecca bye bye thanks for
having me
bye-bye Dan welcome back you don't have
a camera on you do you I don't well your
voice is all we need baby um
so happy to be here we're glad to do
like a little ASMR thing I love when
you're here I I I hate it when you're
not everyone does but specifically me
not everyone
welcome to the uh bathroom hour
I had my uh so sorry we got to go to
break moment
what happened so uh was set in chat
I didn't send it but uh because I was
listening to check to make sure that was
the right video
I wished you know how I could switch
between their audio and then my laptop
yeah yeah I was on my laptop but I heard
their voice but it was through the
YouTube video so it was delayed so when
I interrupted they weren't talking from
my end but I had it on the wrong input
um
you know it's another Another Day
audio is slightly delayed there he is
social media clip baby
um well I have exciting news if I may uh
tickets for the Rocks here on sale
really yeah May 13th
nice let's go baby pretty excited about
that if you want tickets it's on uh my
socials in the bio
let's go
we uh last night
uh Ian converted more of the crew to uh
Avatar fans
we went uh me Sam Ian Lena and Olivia
and uh
I think we're all on board for the most
part
Olivia ran out in the last half yeah
Olivia walked out so I don't think she's
on board but uh yeah it sounded like
everybody else had a good time yeah is
that the case
Sam what did you think are you are you
back there
and I just thought it was entirely too
long
like the first hour of that movie was so
unnecessary but I liked the last two
hours when they got to the water it got
good it's all about the way of water
it's true well I mean I want to see it
now I do know the way of waters yeah and
the tolkoons yeah I haven't seen that
dog [__] movie but I like saying
tolkoons uh I gotta reset up my buttons
really quick so hey guys it's gonna be
on this shot for a moment Cameron Grant
everybody Cameron Grant says gentlemen
cam go [__] socks kid go south they
just beat the Lakers he's telling Cam
he's pretty brave to wear that Celtics
thing after the Lakers got [__]
robbed this week I mean the Lakers
[__] sucked this season nothing and
this isn't Sports talk right now but I
don't know the Lakers [__] suck the
Celtics are number one this season I
love them I just wanted to sit here
because there's empty chairs I want to
say hello to everybody Cameron grants
everybody Cameron everybody
yeah go baby how you doing cam good I
didn't see Avatar 2 with you guys
yesterday because I saw everything
everywhere all at once in theaters I
[__] loved it I hope it goes the
distance at the Academy Awards this year
hell yeah I love that movie you did oh
yeah I really did yeah it's in theaters
again if you guys want to see that if
you already saw Avatar 2. the crazy
thing about that and I'm so happy is the
the little kid that was in Indiana Jones
is now probably gonna win a [__]
Oscar and that's wild I hope so
he was like my favorite part of the
movie
um but yeah shout out shout out got The
Goonies yeah The Goonies shout out
Encino Man yeah oh yeah Encino Man
uh I don't know what else he was in
that's all I got uh he was in Indiana
Jones completely delayed shout out
Indiana Jones well also a connection
there Brennan Frazier was an Encino Man
Who is uh also nominated for an Oscar
shout out shout out Brendan Fraser shout
out the whale you know yesterday when we
were going to watch the movie I had to
miss the first 15 minutes because I went
to go use the bathroom and uh I was like
on my phone waiting for Alina and then I
saw like someone run by and then a lady
came out she's like did you see my kid I
lost my kid and I was like oh [__] no I
didn't then she started to freak out and
she told the staff person next to me can
you watch my other kid let's go look for
him kids love him and I know what the
[__] to do like I
I went back to the theater for a second
I saw Ian and Lena and Marlena's like oh
we're over here she wait so this lady
asked you to watch a stranger to watch
her child well I was next to a staff
person that's why I didn't know if she
was like talking to the staff and then I
went to go watch the movie and I'm like
[__] man if this kid goes missing it's
gonna be on the news that this guy just
went back to go watch Avatar so
I had to go try to find this kid we
found him by the way kids love okay I
already found him yeah it was
I'm very fun that's all the happy ending
yeah happy ending happy ending but you
missed the first 15 minutes of the movie
which are pretty boring I think the
first fully and deliberately stepped on
her hands I feel like he knew exactly
what he was doing I feel like I was
sitting here we stormed the capital but
yeah I know
I think it's very brave of you to come
up here and I saw you alone I was like I
appreciate it let me go sit with my
buddy I've I've uh
oh
what the hell beautiful stuff for you
here love I wish you were in this third
seat oh yeah oh thank you guys thank you
guys I'm working on it very very hard
there's there's so much going on in the
background right now everyone's saying
goodbye we're just trying to kill some
dead air we're hoping we're doing okay
Ian how was your second time uh viewing
Avatar
oh Ian's working he's not working he
just likes to talk
why we're um why we're here no doing
this oh
just uh was this the plan to like just
like keep doing the show well initially
because initially it was only supposed
to be an hour but then we switched it to
go a little longer so uh I see so there
was a plan to to go yeah okay
come on
we gotta talk about Mr Beast you say
yeah Mr yeah Mr Beast he's uh healing
color blindness God blessed blindness
all colors Logan Paul does the color
blindness that's right yeah which is
color blindness of A Sort right these
glasses have changed my life
Mr brust Mr breast
um him turn uh water into wine in that
last video dude I can't wait for his uh
walking on water video yeah wait that
came out last week you didn't see that
oh I didn't I missed that I didn't have
my uh like those like uh chameleons or
like those little lizards that like do
the little skitter across the surface of
the water sweet yeah is he turning into
Jesus
I heard he's uh rebuilding the Twin
Towers wow yeah out of Orbeez actually
at Orbeez yeah
wow the dementia did I mention uh Zach
Lewis over the Roxy May 13th I'll be
there what's the date uh May 13th May
13th tickets on sale now it's on sale
now just went and checked they are in
fact on sale now
nice I'll get mine today no you should I
got you Cam oh thank you I was just
trying to do it 11. there you go pick up
tickets everybody
I forgot we're on Tick Tock we're on
Tick Tock too hi Tick Tock what's up
Terry tots what's up tater tots idiots
if Ethan's your new dad were your older
brothers
well he said yeah
little bro have we uh is that guy
responded the uh uh Italian world record
Guy what's his name Rocco oh I don't
know he's been real quiet yeah he's
avoiding me yeah yeah when is Sam
yeah he don't want the he don't want the
smoke you don't want this [__] [__]
smoked him
check this [__] out do I not have a
camera
uh yeah you should I think Olivia's
cameras on doing some uh reconfiguration
there we go hey work you're looking good
thank you guys both the violations not
in sight working on the oil uh mines
their partner the oil mines yeah
[Music]
do the Texas say old is that true do
they say what I'm darn oh oh oh oh wait
wait I want to get that clean say that
again
oh
[Laughter]
say big old Texas love
no that's not what I mean big old
titties love cooking all oh oil what
what right what do you put in your car
love
oh they said that they said that I swear
to God just check shot is there anything
is there anyone in chat from Texas
cooking oil
in Tennessee says uh no we don't so yeah
no we don't okay never mind they all
agree with me
[Music]
I know my heart's beating a million
miles per minute oh yeah yo me too baby
yeah are you doing the Paul Road meme
right now though
wait nmp Lord tricked me bro
I
uh I'm not in your seat as much as you
like to blame me Cam's in your I'm in
your seat I'm sorry we're killing dead
air out here
let me
I got tricked by a twitch streamer he
said it's called all so I think all the
Texans say all
you know I love I'm gonna say oil too
oil oh
nmp Lord from odk say that you tricked
me dude
they say all in Georgia sometimes look
that one guy agrees with me right there
but what do they say in Arizona
that's where you're from
what do they say in Arizona
oh oh they say old oh
yeah yeah the great old debate
he said what are you doing in my seat
and it went to uh the bathroom
nice trying to carry this show here fam
I know what are we supposed to do I
don't know but I bought a vest guys hand
in the seat I bought a vest the first
time since I was a kid I don't know how
I feel about it it looks good we feeling
the best it looks good it looks good I
don't like puffy vests I'm sorry it's
not you it's not that veg I'm just not a
fan of the look I think it works on him
thank you thank you thank you buddy get
your members go up for donating
700. oh yeah so baby
the puffer fish right the one that turns
into a circle crazy
[Laughter]
I got there that's the one I miss making
Dan laugh last week or it was just on uh
you were just out on Friday I was really
just gone Friday yeah
did you talk about your trip how's your
trip
it was good I went I went to Idaho
uh which is where my girlfriend Allison
is from she's dealing with some some
family stuff up there uh and so she's
been up there for like a month and uh I
went up to uh
go visit her for a while because I
missed her be a supportive King don't
say good morning he's a good man some
people thought you quit people thought I
quit they thought you quit because you
guys
you're never leaving
baby
that's all I know baby's my go-to now
baby I think it's my friend who always
wears the bestest baby so I've been it's
in your brain it's my brain baby sad
because he works at a gas station people
always walk was like what's up my babies
okay once the rose off the tongue pretty
nice yeah baby oh yeah
the capital
I I charge the Capitol Building here
it's been fun
thanks everybody I leave for once again
these guys are co-opting my [__] I
mean what are we supposed to do why
didn't we wrap up the show at the end of
the interview like what are we doing
here well I planned on doing I didn't
know how long it was gonna go so I
planned on talking about some stuff I
see afterwards is that okay Dan it's
okay I was just I was really thrown off
I was getting ready to call for the
closing music and right thanks
so originally she said that they could
only do one hour right okay we're like
oh we'll do some more show afterwards
what you want but actually what are we
talking about
Mississippi
I want to debrief a little bit
so
it seems like there's something going on
between
Patrice she didn't tell me anything but
she couldn't talk about anything with
Patrice so I'm assuming there's some
legal stuff going on there
but one thing I did learn that was super
interesting is
um
they put it up without her knowing
that's pretty [__] and you know what's
crazy now
um
they want to own the [__] song it
sounds like or I'm inferring
she didn't tell me anything
she was very tight-lipped but it's like
they got paid to make it they put it up
without a permission and then now they
want to own it
it's [__] crazy
guess the shortest
is this on the website
I'll check found a mushroom in the
garden
I don't know if it's new or
by the way I want to look at um
I heard that Patrice made some magazine
sounds awesome can you guys find it I
think it's on YouTube
yeah look about storming the capital
he's Pro storming the capital
I don't even think the storming the
capital people are pro-storming the
capital okay
no they're all like oh [__] antifa I
love it right it's either antifa or the
people got arrested were like [__] I
thought it was I didn't know I was doing
anything illegal very special
well that's what happened with the Tiger
King dudes
like they showed up on January 6 and
allegedly left after they stormed the
capital and we're like we were just here
to free Joe Exotic like
wait what yeah in Tiger King 2 do you
remember that like they went to January
6th because Trump was having the rally
and they're like oh they wanted to say
pardon Joe Exotic exactly and I let they
apparently left after they stormed the
capital
and they're like well we didn't know
what happened we left you know oh
someone asked will steamies be live or
pre-recorded we will be live on
Wednesday at one o'clock with tana and
Jeff it is going to be
spec papular
took uh Rebecca to check out Teddy fresh
good times good she got her box yes nice
wow what a cool uh what a cool girl and
a cool interesting story
I think that's amazing that she's able
to
survive I agree with a career out of
that it's
it's really cool to be able to talk to
her after all these years it's like
it's almost like watching like a really
great documentary but you're
experiencing it in real life I just
I'm so curious about all the Patrice
stuff but I know she couldn't do it
she couldn't do it
do you guys find the mega [__] I want to
find this mega song he put out I think I
may have just found it it's not even
Mega it's like more it's like Pro
Insurrection it's awesome
you know I've been watching so much
[__] oh my God so I kept seeing
people say talk about atriak
and I was like I don't know who this is
I just looked it up and this looks
extremely cringe holy [__] wait is that
Patrice Wilson thing no no this is
totally unrelated
this is a twitch twitch streamer who
from what I'm reading accidentally
showed his uh his Chrome tabs or
whatever and had deep fake porn of
pokemane and uh and Maya
uh miskov's accent yes yes uh uh up on
the screen oh my God and he's a big
streamer I guess
Milk porn you know it's way better than
me do you know who atriot is yeah he's a
decently big streamer decently big
screen show me the picture
well what looks really cringe is he did
an apology and he's there with what
looks like his wife or girlfriend oh my
God
brutal oh and this just happened
uh yeah I guess so yeah this is
published yeah just a few hours ago okay
should we watch Patrice Wilson first or
do this twitch then
this twitch thing sounds fresh that
sounds great the twitch thing I think
probably this is give this so he oh I've
just been informed by our by the Saudi
Prince of all people that atriak is part
of Ludwig's uh yeah he's like not whole
circle
by the way members go up our Saudi
benefactor has been going ape [__] I
didn't get an opportunity to say
anything
but how much how many Subs did he get
like 700 memberships dude what the
fridge
thank you our Saudi benefactor
it's awesome thank you dude
uh everyone is saying twitch for sure
okay yeah Madison loved my fam from
South Texas says water
you're right cam my fam from
nor NE
thank you I just want to I want to
acknowledge all the sparkling water the
generous folks
oh Jake said towards a new mic Dan I
don't know what that means
all right we got this story here
so he already posted a how long between
him getting caught and posting an
apology video was there uh it seems
pretty much on January 30th the clip
claiming to expose Adriatic for looking
at Deep fakes of other streamers gain
traction
and oh he paid for them he bought them
it's not even like he was like found he
paid for them Lord this is so it's dude
that's career ending Pokey Main and Ms
kiff's ex-girlfriend Maya oh God
dude but the fact that he actually went
up there and paid for them it feels like
oh it's in the dock
this is okay here it is I got it so last
night after one of atriax streams
fans pointing out that in a brief moment
his tabs were exposed
and amongst the tabs was a deep fake
website where's the picture
oh is it like full-blown nudity in it
oh yeah
okay but I thought it was just the tab
like the text on the tab
can you show me the picture just on
Discord so I can see just what what it
was that
what
shake that is
I want to see what was leaked bro
what do you mean
I'm a rep I'm a reporter I shouldn't
have that all the information I want to
know what people saw it's not crazy
yeah obviously the website where he got
it I'm not going to mention these people
are freaks
so obviously not going to give them any
clout
uh
let's see here's the clip of him
apologizing I've been watching so much
oh my God bro if this guy just beat off
and now he's crying on stream
I mean he was enjoying them so much that
he had the tab open
like how long ago
he must have beat off like super
recently to that [__] I had a beat off
bro you ever gone from jerking off to
crying on stream in this short of
duration that's way crazy so that's his
wife but this apology like when did that
happen I think it just happened and when
did that yesterday
let's see
so
oh wait here's the article that says it
I don't know who this guy is how many
how many what how many views does he get
uh
oh I see they're they're removing it at
all
violating content policy I guess
the Deep fake thing is uh
bad juju
cutie used to pay some company two
thousand dollars every month to have
fakes and Coomer content of her deleted
from the internet
well
so this is I guess a huge problem I'm
not super aware of this
but I guess so there's websites that do
like super realistic deep fakes I guess
that you can pay
and then this comment
how do you say his name is paying the
same people 2500 to keep them online
oh [__] that is so embarrassing
600 000 average fears
yeah so it's quite pretty big
wait he's here's something he's talking
about AI monstrous 2023. so remember how
every single person on the internet was
getting involved in crypto and nfts and
talking about all the crypto startups
and all of that everybody's pivoting the
new buzzword
to AI the only thing is the difference
this time is that AI actually has real
world application the amount of money
being poured into it is astronomical
this is a photo of the party that is AI
that you're not invited to every human
in this photo is not real this is all I
mean it looks kind of weird I'm not
super surprised does she have too many
teeth am I tripping yeah
how much teeth you got translate that
Titan
all right you guys ready
for this apology I'm trying to savor
this I don't wanna
wait but can we see when he got caught
so January 30th
is when he got caught
this website which I'm not gonna name um
sells access to deep fake images and
videos of female twitch streamers
including Pokemon hiya
Maya and cutie Cinderella
so
they're allowed to sell it I don't
I don't actually know
um I don't know it seems to me that that
would probably be illegal yeah some kind
of like copyright slash likeness
uh uh violation
also I think the nature of the content
makes it
more egregious because like I know for
example when you're talking about
defamation when you're talking about
things like you know assault or CP or
stuff like the defamation becomes easier
to prove because it's so gross what
you're accusing them of
fans noticed after the Stream
foreign
was it just the tab that said the
website name or what you actually saw
them they show it showed the photos too
so he had the tab like open he yeah he
was a very blurry picture and but
afterwards
it was a very blurry picture
nothing visible and then people cross
reference oh my God I found them already
y'all cannot get away with [__] by the
way I showed my DMs and my browser
history so many times you guys know that
I'm not a fan
really got
that bro I just like showed my whole
[__] the other day I showed all my
DMs not like literally but I opened up
my all my DMs
am I hearing static or is that the AC
just turn yeah I don't know how you keep
doing that okay so here's the here oh
I'm not don't show the screen for a
second in case it shows up
okay no you're good
dude it's so blurry I can't even tell
what I'm looking at like how did they oh
I see
I see they're seeing like lots of photos
oh I see so he he clicked the button
where it shows all your tabs real fast
yeah it shows like which by the way
Windows really [__] that feature by
the way has ruined so many lives
this dude was so deep into the fact that
he left that [__] open that's like not
one it's like 50. also he didn't even go
Incognito for this [__] like damn bro
holy [__] man
it the fact that he paid for it makes it
so much worse
yeah I agree
but also the fact that it's other
streamers like specific people
makes it very bad
yeah that's that's really really gross
dude
holy [__]
yeah I'm not gonna give any details
about the website or anything you know
obviously these people are scumbag
I just want to understand the story
so yeah he got caught with his hand in
his pants so to speak
the website a few hours after the clip
went viral a truck appeared on stream
with his partner oh so it was just a
couple hours later and it went on stream
with his wife
why does she have to sit through that
dude I don't know we're gonna watch it
though I don't know that this one minute
clip is gonna be enough for me you guys
I might need the whole damn thing
this is so embarrassing he said send it
oh this is what he said he says I've
been taking a keen interest in AI deep
fake technology such as a IR
I was it was research
disappreciating art dude I was just
marveling at the power of AI on this
paywall website
[Laughter]
but I was on a regular website and there
was an ad on every video and then I
click it and then I'm in this Rabbit
Hole I got morbidly curious and I
clipped something it's gross and I'm
sorry and I'm embarrassed oh
I mean can he can he even honestly say
like yeah I paid for this and I was
beating off to them like you ha he needs
to be like because we all know that's
what happened yeah but he's got to be
like no it's just a AI rabbit hole and
yeah
there's no clean way I did this
he claimed that it was not a pattern of
behavior they had only looked at it once
he said he could show the receipt to
prove he purchased access to the site on
the same day as the clip was made all
right let's see it
industry and it's so gross oh would you
say like really he said that almost the
issue is not him doing whatever it's
like just supporting that gross
disgusting industry of people like just
like unconsensually like posting nudes
of other people it reminds me of um yeah
what was that website we watched the
documentary of the is anyone up where
they were it's like Revenge p word yes
yeah totally that terrible guy
yeah the worst guy on the internet I
think that was the name of it
yeah that's it
so
following the apology there yeah I
wonder what's the legality of all this
because it can't be illegal I would feel
terrible
it can't be legal there's no way I mean
I don't think it's illegal what he did
but I'm pretty sure it's illegal what
they're doing it's a business yeah yeah
yeah I mean it should be obviously all
this Tech is so new there's like they're
selling like a weird I mean they're
selling pictures of them
right but I mean they could probably
argue in court that it's that it's uh
because it's not real it's just like a
original yeah but they're using the
likeness or whatever I mean I guess
yeah the selling I guess they could
probably get them on if there was no
sale I think they'd have a good right
argument but I don't know I think it's
more like a generator so they'll be like
submit what people you want in the
detail probably and then they do it
that's how they get away with it but
think about this a lot lately all this
like the AI is like the whole this is
the new thing they're like all the
discourse is about and it's not just
like stuff like this is like the AI art
and then there's like the chat GPT thing
and it's like
like with so many things you know this
revolutionary technology
and all it's being used for porn
seemingly is like porn and like the AI
art thing is like destroying the market
for like actual artists and like I just
saw another thing the other day that now
there's like an AI that can make music
and it's like where's the AI that gets
rid of [__] boys sir where's the AI
that like goes after that can be a CEO
of a company you know what I mean like
it's it's always
right seems to be pointed in the
direction of vulnerable people that are
just trying to get by you know what I
mean like it's just so annoying to me
all huge technological breakthroughs
were to build missiles to kill
people right and then now all the great
technological breakthroughs are so that
you can uh see people uh have uh being
porn all right it's just like and I'm
sure the next great AI breakthrough is
going to be so that you can have sex
with a robot I do awesome I have
recently came across this Instagram page
of AI clothing
and they do
um I saw like they do really cool shoe
designs like Nike I don't know if any of
you guys saw them I'll I'll show you
because
I'm like in love with the designs
but I mean I don't know where you go
from there it's not like so this AI is
making shoe designs yeah and they're
cool they are really cool but like
in reality real people will need to
actually make it so I'm not sure
well yeah that's the heart I mean that's
one of those parts designing is a hard
part but making it's also a hard part
uh I'm pretty sure GB is
uh taking legal action against one of
these deep things really good for her
she could actually maybe make a
important precedent then
send it on WhatsApp no of course I'm
just on my phone
let me just said chat GPT pass a simple
bar exam recently
interesting
watch out watch how quick it gets shut
down now that uh it goes after people
that can actually do something about it
so I have a friend who did a bachelor's
in engineering and he he was just he he
was just playing around with that AI GPT
or whatever it's called and he said like
he it wrote his a whole like he could
have wrote his whole exam with that
completely without any input extra like
editing here you go Dan I'm a
microbiologist and I use AI to predict
the relationship between diet and the
gut yeah I just saw that and I just
thought there's another one that said I
do AI uh in cancer research we're not
all bad okay I mean that's great that's
great that shit's boring
but it's Pro I'm sure it's happening by
the way I've been good we got to get on
chat GPS I'm super curious about that
yeah I want to try it GPT I wonder if it
whatever Chad
so here's GB official she does ASMR
Friends of the show yeah yeah
she put this out in November she says
hail serious topic and honestly just a
tiny blip in the conversation my
experience is not unique which is why I
feel compelled to speak out I can tell
and Canon will truly happen to anyone I
hope you take a listen to help me take
action against Steve figs
uncomfortable
I usually make content that is
entertaining relaxing both hopefully
but I feel very compelled to speak out
in order to add in my experience to
countless others
in hopes that we can finally start
getting some help
there is a lot of porn of me on the
internet
that may surprise you or it might not
I had no choice my face has been
digitally plastered countless times over
other people's naked bodies to create
sex content that I never consented to
porn of myself I never created has been
viewed distributed and sold it has been
used to threaten humiliate and attempt
to grab power from myself
and my reality is not unique even among
my peers so many of us have had these
same exact experience
and it kills me to know that this is an
inevitability that future Generations
will also be victim to
and even worse because technology
advances so quickly
right now the laws surrounding deep fake
porn and other intimate image abuse are
almost a non-existent
it has felt hopeless and that's crazy
unsafe
to ever speak out however I am relieved
to finally be talking about this with
some support
I was reached out to by my image my
choice
it's a group of very hard-working
activists who are openly pushing for
change
and becoming a resource for the
countless people who have been targeted
and abused by others online
so I am finally looking into what I can
do especially because I received a very
interesting message recently and that's
the other part of my story that I wanted
to address
a lot of people wrongfully think that
deep fake porn is a joke or that because
I post my face publicly I deserve this
but it can happen to anyone
I was contacted by someone who thinks
she has actually discovered the identity
of the of a person who has created
um I wanna that'd be a good conversation
to have with her yeah we should reach
out to her
that's terrible
I would hate the idea of that out there
of myself well I hate to tell you what
it is that's terrible
yeah I mean I think every every woman
probably in entertainment's got one of
those floating around somewhere
all right so anyway here let's see the
apology
this is what I'm here for
you know I've been watching so much
[__] I've been reading so much
[__] AI stuff uh reading all this
[__] stuff about Ai and and uh and
[__] defect music art and everything
and I'm in these [__] discords and I
was I feel so embarrassing of me but I
was on [__] PornHub dude I was on a
[__] regular ass normal website and
there was an ad there's an ad on every
[__] video for this [__] so I know
other people must be clicking it because
it's on every [__] video for [__]
defecting and then I click it and I'm
[__] in this [__] rabbit hole and
at 2AM I [__]
I I don't know I got morbidly curious
and like click something and I and I
it's just [__] I don't know it's
morbidly curious more like uh
sexually curious
2 A.M I know I know the senior setting
[__] my wife's asleep
the the intro that clipped yes please
thank you Dan just pointed out it
sounded like he was about to say I've
been watching so much [__] porn
I've never seen this dude I cringe
tolerances oh you know who made that
this is brutal you know who made that um
Sam's cousin made that for us right Sam
I get that right
sorry yeah
what were you saying sorry again
oh I I was just saying this is
unbelievably cringe it's painful and the
start of the clip it sounds like he's
about to say I've been watching so much
[__] porn I know that's what they
thought he was saying I've been watching
so much AI porn man
I don't know what's real anymore it's
gross and I'm sorry I really am I really
[__] it it's not
I feel bad laughing at this embarrassing
couple crying yeah that's pretty brutal
yeah but
I just really want to get across it's
not like a [__] pattern of behavior
and I you know I don't I don't know what
I want to say or not but the wife
inclusion is pretty weird really weird
but okay I mean what what do we say to
the guy you know what I mean at the end
of the day what do we say
is this I mean I don't know well so he's
I mean the thing is he's like trying to
claim that he just like
accidentally bought it like I don't know
I think I think he he's too humiliated
to say what really happened but he's I
think he's getting as close as he can
say to saying he did it to jerk off
without actually saying it yeah he's
basically said he died and I was curious
2 A.M bro
down the PornHub Rabbit Hole yeah
hey play give me some sad music Zach
I'm just so sorry that you know I've
been so in I've been chatting with chat
GPS GPS
and I started to imagine it was a woman
and then I went to this website and I
don't know how it happened I I fell
asleep in my head hit the keyboard and
then I woke up
and then the dog clicked there the dog
clicked enter it auto filled my credit
card and then the dog jumped up to say
hi and it hit enter
I did not come on my door I'm just so
sorry and I'm so embarrassed and at
least
once I was in I did yeah I looked around
I was morbidly curious I looked through
it from between 2 A.M and 8 AM when my
wife woke up I was on there for four
hours doing research on AI do not come
I was exhausted it was a long night
hold on I'm coming
fact I sustained a arm injury
from so much vigorous research
[Music]
and uh I'm just so so sorry
I have saved all the files to my hard
drive and backed them up I promise I'll
remove those that was just for AI
database coming
[Music]
what happened
what's up how are you fixing it
oh you're gonna be in the shot with me
here yeah yeah all right I'm just so
sorry I don't know if you have any
thoughts about this
I don't know if you have any thoughts
about this
but the fact that they're like his
co-workers makes it weirder that's like
that makes it so much more uncomfortable
yeah his contemporaries
I'm so sorry
I'm sorry to say this because it's going
to make you really uncomfortable but
that's almost like I'm not even gonna
say it
I was gonna make an analogy
yeah
it's like me looking up deep fakes of
Zach okay yeah thank you for saying that
yeah which I do yeah it is it is like
that actually
well I'm flattered you don't need the
Deep fix bro Jake Zach will show you his
dick brother he already offered once I
think no I often look at my dick but oh
you want to see mine that offers on the
table man thank you buddy sanding offer
that's consensual though it's a new day
when you can say I was gonna say but I'm
not gonna say it and then you actually
don't say it yeah I've been through a
lot
last year in big trouble how many
strikes did we get last year two or
three two
yeah yeah we have zero now that's right
stay winning H3 podcast I'm defeated I
don't think we're gonna get a strike
this whole year
me neither I'm just gonna think positive
there it is people knock on wood
everybody yep to the Moon baby
if I do get a strike would it be for
death threats or racial slur or what do
you think
um probably the death threats yeah yeah
that's a hot that's a hobby yeah no
that's for me right now you're not
you're off the right well I almost said
years and years and years I don't know
if you were here but I I almost said uh
restarted but like not oh yeah no on
leftovers yeah yeah yeah I don't know if
you get I don't know if you it's not
racial yeah it's a slur though yeah I
don't know if you know what's YouTube's
policy on that word I don't think
they'll get a strike for that one yeah I
don't think so either Rises to that
level all right dude I'm gonna watch
this
oh hell yeah I love the beginning
dude the focus and everything is awesome
you ready to do this babe
somebody in the chat says somebody said
cutie was crying on stream 20 minutes
ago oh no that's so sad oh God this is
so bad it's one of the girls he was
watching Cinderella was I don't know I
don't know if but she's on those
websites and I guess she's talked about
this issue before and how she it affects
her
she's the girlfriend she's popular and
own right but she's the girlfriend of
Ludwig
and they know each other yeah they're
part of the same Social Circle so yeah
wow yeah this isn't a stranger
to her yeah
oh my God bro that's uncomfortable
it's so bad
oh my she was crying about this oh this
is girlfriend so that's so sad
yeah she's been working hard to kind of
prevent it and for this for it to be in
like the Limelight like this just
promote it even more she's been right is
that true somebody said cutie baked his
wedding cake
cutie she's a baker she bakes stuff yeah
oh wait okay she has like a cooking show
I think that's too much dude so she
baked his wedding cake
and what's interesting is that I guess
because I'm not super familiar with all
these people
a big thing for her was paying to remove
this stuff from the internet
and he's bang pain people to make it
mama
that's a spicy hot mama
[Music]
whoa
that sucks yeah this is like Hazmat
level Korean just see people posting
yeah this is already a 2024 steamies
Contender
now that is a spicy meatball I'm already
calling it
she's a shoe-in man this is a ward bait
if I've ever seen it
all right let's watch this [__] [__]
that's sad I'm sorry cutie
Mamma Mia did
is there no sound or they didn't turn it
on you
oh I can hear
is it quiet what's happening
they're relatively quiet yeah there's
about like five minutes to build up here
I guess if you're okay here we go just
give it a few minutes obviously
let the stream populate yeah that's so
lame just make a [__] video bro
there's even a fart I mean I get
I guess it's admirable that he
immediately addressed it fully you know
what I mean like people familiar he came
out and he didn't like Dodge it or make
like a Notes app thing he immediately
hopped on stream and was like that's
what I was trying to say that it's like
what can you at this point look he he
did it he jerked off to the to weird
[__] yeah
he's like not fully admitting that he
like paid for it or whatever no no he
said I paid for it I clicked the ad at
2AM I paid for it out of morbid
curiosity right okay he's based I mean
you know yeah he he's I do it with
everyone although the one part that I
didn't like was when he was like um the
ad is everywhere on PornHub I can't be
the only one clicking it
yeah well he's like we're all doing it
it's like aren't you tell me I'm not the
only one no
why does it lie well he's not
wrong if they can afford to buy a bunch
of ads on PornHub but it's not exactly
it doesn't actually sound good when
you're trying to defend yourself some
people saying he made content out of it
I I mean I don't know if this is
do you ignore it like that's way worse
obviously yeah you got to address it all
right let's watch this I'm dying I'm
definitely gonna address everything
today but you know if you if you say
something
way over the line I I asked the monster
stop it but I I'm not like trying to
hide anything or I'm gonna talk about it
all
just I don't know if you could if you
could keep it just
send my civil that would help thank you
what do you say
semi-civil stay well I'll keep it civil
just be like I jerked off the weird [__]
I'm sorry if you just give me like five
minutes I'll talk about it
dude twitch is the craziest uh drama go
ahead Zach play the chestnuts
[Music]
you know what when he paid for it and
started beating off to the future if it
was in a movie that's the song that
would play I'm gonna talk about it in
five minutes yes
[Music]
yeah I think like 7.5
oh it's just five minutes away dude
let me skip it then
oh he really is just mourning I want to
say a couple of facts early I just I
want to get him out of the way because
it's only because I I was torturing him
he lives
that made me feel sick to my stomach he
doesn't they took it he says he lives
with Ludwig that's [__] crazy no no
no no no no no
um that can't be it's an awkward dinner
did we fact check that
I'm looking
oh yeah everybody uh go out there and
make some clips
the H3 industrial complex is in business
there's a clip go look for the clip
yes thank you keemstar
out of the way because it's only because
I I was torturing myself reading the
[__] lsf comments that made me feel
sick to my stomach and they're they're
way too far they took it way way too far
so
I I don't know if I should include this
or not but I have the [__]
the receipt thing right here this was it
which was it's from the exact same day
that that [__] clip is from all right
there's no pattern of behavior can I
just say that doesn't really prove
anything I mean he could have gone and
got another receipt
the [__] tab open or and it was it or
I guess he wouldn't have an old one I
don't know whatever what would it even
prove I don't get it at all that he just
had it for one day he only beat I swear
I only beat off to it one time well he
was on PornHub saw an ad and bought the
product it's like you were clearly we
under we know what you were doing bro
come on
what the [__] I think he's trying to
minimize it saying that I haven't been
in doing this I only just got into it
he's trying to say like I'm not
I'm not a medium-sized yeah
and also I'm so bad at this that I did
it once and instantly got caught like 10
minutes later bro you left the tab open
that means he had a good jerk though
that means he loved it because he like
beat off so hard and so deep that he
left that [__] open and he's a streamer
like he knows better than anyone not to
do that plans on returning I think yeah
maybe he didn't want to pay again yeah
oh he's going back leave it open oh I
don't think you have to pay again that'd
be crazy you probably just log in I
would assume forgot his password maybe
but that makes sense for ease of access
you leave it open also why are you
putting your credit card into something
like that like your sh your info is so
stolen dude like I'm like that is so
stupid I think that happened to us once
oh yeah where we bought something weird
online and then we kept getting a bunch
of scam alerts I think maybe the furry
suit
what would you pay with like Bitcoin I
mean yeah you could I guess do crypto
not everybody's like crypto I think a
lot of people are probably getting their
IDs stolen yeah I think you're right Dan
yo you're in trouble because you're
basically you're basically giving
criminals they're already by default
like criminals yeah like why would you
put your credit card information that's
insane I guess there's so many reasons
oh well that's interesting someone said
on the upside he can now write it off on
his taxes he made a video about it nice
oh God
2 A.M but by the way [__] PornHub for
promoting that [__] out of town like yo
I get it dude you need ads but come on
seriously you guys
that's gross
can we get McDonald's ads or something
on PornHub I don't see why not
there's nothing better than beating off
and then getting a cheeseburger
like what's wrong with that exactly oh
this is sad here's Cutie's video but I
feel bad even watching it it's I mean I
don't know if you guys do or don't but
she's it's she's just crying sad
let's watch it I guess right I mean it's
good context I just don't want I don't
know I just want to do the right thing
here I don't know what that is well
maybe we can put it on for a second and
get a Vibe let's finish this there's no
excuse for it I'm not go ahead go ahead
I was gonna say she tweeted about like
her thoughts maybe it would be quicker
to just read her tweets yeah maybe
that's better I'll see if there's a good
tweet I mean the video's short but okay
I mean she put it out she want people to
watch it right that's the theory I think
so yeah I'm wrong especially if we're
watching a camera to also watch her wait
the Tweet says don't hurt me the most is
like
all right here's her tweet she says
she says I want to scream stop everybody
stop stop spreading it
stop advertising it
I don't think we did that right no being
seen naked against your will is not part
of this job
thank you to all the male internet
journalists reporting on this issue
[__] losers
oh I guess so the reason she's saying
that the main reason is because this guy
hunter he posted like a list of everyone
on that website and like almost like
pretty much promoting it oh geez people
were making fun of him
like saying oh how much it's also post a
promo code yeah like you should have
added like a hashtag ad to the tweets
Dash Hunter for uh 10 discount yeah yeah
okay well I think we're a bit we're
abiding by her wishes I don't we I'm not
promoting them at all
right no we haven't said anything about
them
I've done a lot on the stream to like
create a pattern of behavior where I
really want especially women on Twitter
to feel safer like I uh we call [__]
booba spam cringe we don't do that there
I've never made like a [__] weird I
don't know sea sniffing joke I've never
done anything like that yeah I don't
know man I wouldn't even talk about this
stuff
I mean you know just just uh that's so
oddly specific too
like we respect women but you know I
don't know
this is hard it's hard it's not like not
everybody knows how to react I guess and
he's like
he's talking like his career just died
and this is him mourning it they'll
probably be fine but I'll tell you what
man he's not gonna have a relationship
with those people anymore
yeah that's the thing it's not even
about like if if if this is his Social
Circle
this is like that's really wrong
friendships you're losing your best
friend there was a kid in my high school
he was a cool guy he had lots of friends
popular
apparently he borrowed his friend's
um cam camera
and when he returned it was like an old
school VHS because I'm old as [__] yeah
and when he returned it to him he forgot
to erase a video he took of him putting
a comb up his ass
and gum he put gum and with and a comb
up his ass
fantastic and then his friends basically
showed everybody and uh he had to move
schools
yeah yeah I I heard this story through
somebody
but it was someone I knew in high school
yeah
[Music]
what so is it like that or Worse okay he
put yeah the handle of a comb up his ass
he was doing [__] okay and gum I
don't know why gum I don't know the gum
but that's what I don't know why my mind
just immediately went to like the
bristles no not the bristle side the
handle Dan probably the only place he
could up his ass
my friend Neil actually
a stream that's a wild story we don't
tolerate any sex behavior in the chat oh
we banned it on site
and uh and like I've done this
consistently over over and over and then
[__] at 2am
you know I've been watching so much
[__] I've been reading so much
[__] AI stuff
this is not
you know I don't that doesn't matter all
I hear is like I've been watching so
much [__] porn or something like that
that's almost what came out in my head
oh this shot is so funny they're like
spamming Hearts like someone has passed
away or something but
they're just supporting some dude
watching porn
we support you bro about Ai and
uh and [__] you take music and
everything and I mean does his wife talk
or is she just sitting there crying she
doesn't talk
oh my God
and I was I feel so embarrassing of me
but I was on [__] PornHub dude I was
on a [__] regular ass normal website
and there was an ad there's an ad on
every [__] video
other people must be clicking it because
it's on every [__] video for [__]
deep fake thing and then I click it and
I'm [__] in this [__] rabbit hole
and at 2AM I [__]
I I don't know I got morbidly curious
and like click something and I and I
it's just [__] it's it's gross it's
gross and I'm sorry I really am I really
[__] it
it's not
I don't know it's a little embarrassing
but
I just really want to get across it's
not like a [__] pattern of Behavior I
got receipts literally I don't know what
I want to say or not but
uh I just hate doing this on stream man
this is not what my stream's about at
all oh my God but I just feel bad and I
saw some comments
for people that are in my community
that were uh that we're talking and they
they felt so let down and it made me
feel so [__] sick
I get it I mean [__] I don't I don't
know that I can watch
let me skip ahead and just see kind of
what's the vibe the charge is from the
26th which is the day the clip is from
he's talking about his receipts though
um
I might I might
I might end it do I I mean here in the
Stream because uh
because I don't want you guys to hear me
repeat myself but let's see what I can
do
all right all right
um cheers
anyway the reason I bring up that story
is he essentially got caught with a comb
and gum up his butt right
so to speak
metaphorically metaphorically of course
[Music]
but that's not a random comb it's like
your friend's comb
right it's yours it's you took your
friend's comb from their house that
they're like wait where's my comb I miss
losing it and then you see that it shows
up in his ass yeah okay we were going to
talk about that funny ass Mr Beast one
thumbnail
I actually haven't watched the video yet
but the thumbnail just we were all kind
of laughing about how crazy it is and I
mean like I'm sure it's wholesome and
good I mean I'm sure right it's a
beautiful wholesome video but look at
this thumbnail Ila
it's a little demonic for some reason
what it's happening here a thousand
blind people see for the first time oh
my God there's just something about
Jimmy being like
and the fake tears
yeah I mean I guess the Demonic thing is
that you need like a [__] influencer
to help these people get preventable
blindness fixed
these people have preventable blindness
and they can only get treatment because
of [__] Mr Beast yeah he's passing
out Health Care like it's a goddamn
canned food drive
yeah it's a 10-minute procedure wow oh
my God that's so sad that's like a third
world country [__] how much does it cost
uh let me find out I just like this
though he's like look what I made this
[__] see again
that is wild
it is funny right I'm not alone yeah
this thumbnail is kind of crazy
I actually haven't seen the video yet
let's watch
this video we're hearing a thousand
um
this didn't get claimed right you guys
tested it yeah it didn't get claimed did
you get out of your system though the
chestnut the chestnut is gone okay
he busted a chestnut yeah
I busted my Chestnut and now I'm closing
all the tabs
canceling all my memberships
yeah
in this video we're hearing a thousand
people's watches
look at all these blind [__] he's like I
brought it together a thousand blind
[__] broke people
dude are these is post-blind or or
appearing or post blind
most of us see the world like this but
here's the thing 200 million people see
the world like this oh that's not good
but I just made it one less
oh
wow that's so she's just one of a
thousand blind people we help from
around the world they can't see but we
have all the time that's great and he's
in half of all the blindness in the
world is people who need a 10-minute
surgery that's crazy yeah that's so
[__] up I'll see everybody oh I Can
See Clearly yeah
they see your face I can see your face I
can see your face if you're wondering
how the surgery allows people to see
again it's because the losing their eye
got so cloudy
through it so the surgeon uses a tiny
vacuum to suck up the clouded lens whoa
it's sucking and replace it with an
artificial one this surgery is that
simple they can see again
you think there was a thousand and one
who's just like sitting there still
blind like damn Jimmy
I was thinking I wonder if they botched
someone's eye like they made it worse
because yeah kind of interesting that
would be really cool and interesting
that'd be a good thumbnail no I don't
think so I think this I don't I don't
think it's a surgery that like people
[__] up
without insurance the cost of cataract
surgery on both eyes is upward to six to
twelve thousand these glasses have
changed my life
[Music]
you pay for my surgery yes is that us or
him that
was him
you know why was that music there why
did it turn into stranger things for
like 10 seconds
yes seriously you know what here's ten
thousand dollars
[Music]
more people
it's not just squeezing hard and we're
just getting started we still have 980
lives left to change there's my watch
I've never seen it before and I had nice
flowers yeah it's actually insane I
wonder how you found all these people
yeah put it together and why isn't there
like a charity or something that can do
that for people dude in America people
are walking around with preventable
balloons yeah that's so crazy
um
yeah did you see uh
Mr BEAST's tweet about this no
so he's like edging on the realization
that uh socialized Healthcare is
probably a good idea show me is he
becoming rattle radicalized I think this
video slightly radicalized Mr Beast by
the way Mr Beast is a saint of course
um um let me see and uh this is awesome
that means he must have spent a [__] he
must have cost him like for A Thousand
Times Ten Thousand what's that's like a
million bucks right
so that's like his budget for everybody
though somehow
it's a great idea though it's like yeah
I don't understand oh yeah go ahead I
don't understand why curable blindness
is uh is a thing yeah why don't
government step in and help even if
you're thinking purely from a financial
standpoint it's hard to see why they
don't uh return on investment on taxes
from people being able to work again
you're so close my friend and you're
like right there careful though Fox news
about to do a segment about your ass
yeah communist Mr communist YouTuber Mr
Beast
okay if you wanna I'm not paying for
those people to see again
yeah exactly why isn't the government
helping people see this is [__]
insane I'd be oh
well is this an online America problem
because he says people from around the
world no it's not and only in America
problem but it is [__] disgusting
that in America the richest country
that's ever existed has people walking
around with curable blindness
I'm pretty sure though in like most
European and Canadian countries where
they have social health care this is not
a problem
as far as I know this is a problem in
third world countries
like the United States yeah exactly
right
yep the life I'm Nolan by the way I'm
Pearl you're Carl I know a guy named
Carl not a good guy Moment of Truth
wow you are pretty anxious
what do you see how long have you not
been able to work for four months did
you hear about the cross-eyed teacher
she couldn't control the pupils I'm
gonna need anesthetics not now doctor
she's like God damn it not now
laughs do you have any more eye jokes
for me doctor
don't doctors are like that they gotta
make a joke all the time Jimmy Lee
he's a [__] doctor
all different flavors cloudiness no
blurriness oh it's perfect now what's it
like I can see everything
I don't need this
this is just like not okay our next
patient is Charlie you're not able to
read any of this text on the TV no it's
an e or something I think he won't know
he wants it I can't wait to see his
reaction Charlie Sees everything like
this and it's made him and his family's
life extremely difficult I was a cashier
of my eyes was getting so bad I couldn't
see how much the money hold on I have an
alternative thumbnail idea for Mr Beast
I can't quite explain it but I think
it's strong
your thoughts Ela
cheers
they should have played that when they
first take their eyes out for the first
time right
is it funny that the first thing these
people have to see is Mr Beast
family yeah not their [__] kids you
know what I mean not whatever they care
about they gotta see Mr beasts in a
camera soy facing three inches he paid
for it he did pay for it they see all
those other people every day except they
don't see them he paid for it that's a
goddamn truth that's right
if I paid for some of that I just
wouldn't want to be there when they open
their eyes being like just not slurping
over open fire
just won't get my vision back so I can
go back you're going to be really happy
after this surgery we'll see after it
trust me you will see when patients go
into surgery you I don't think it's his
place to be talking like that you're not
a doctor bro
there's a chance that they can get their
life back and for Charlie if the surgery
goes well he can go back to work
the first thing you see after 20 years
oh wow blindness you can read it now
you just won ten thousand dollars here
you go oh my gosh
that is awesome these people are
problems
I didn't goddamn seen that much money in
one time man
yes see that's not a good place to make
fun of someone's accent no it's not yeah
it's like
not a good situation to be in no
you know I just I need to be better
almost you you good today man I used to
have a crickets button yeah thank God
you don't
my name is back yeah I promise to be
better and I will not be making fun of
anyone's accent
in a situation like this
I mean I wonder like no seriously though
why isn't there a charity or something
already that can do that for people yeah
there probably is there is yeah like
there's so many people that need the
surgery yeah yeah my my guess is that's
probably how he found all these people
in some existing Clinic that had like a
waiting list or some sort of Charity
donation list or something that he
approached and was like hey I'll I'll
pay for everybody on your list well not
everybody just a thousand that's enough
the show I mean I'm not I'm not trying
to downplay this show is dysfunctional
right now okay because Zach is taking
you can't take the controls into your
own hands Zach I said Play The chestnut
song as I read after I did the accent
was apologizing and Zach is refusing to
play it now Zach we cannot run a show
like this
you know what I mean
you're not gonna play a chestnut song
Chestnut might be needing a timeout
I think you need a timeout man possible
too what the [__] I think this show has
gone on for long enough this is
dysfunctional at this point you're just
like you guys are being a little ableist
I'm being honest dude I have Tourette's
bro and you're not playing the chestnut
song for me [__] you Zach
I feel like I'm in an alternate universe
I feel like this is not real bro what is
going on today
oh my God all right you know what Zach's
the one who said who plays no I'm
falling on the grenade for him no sick
of it no
no just play it for me this is this show
is just notches
all right
let me give you a challenge
at the most inappropriate time in this
video play the chestnut song
I'm giving you a standing order from
your general okay but I feel like
and I feel like it the bit it's
overplayed now like I feel like to
marinate no it's perfectly marinated now
because we took it too far and when you
take it too far it gets funny again Zach
okay okay leave the comedy to me okay
okay man you oh aye aye Captain he's the
captain yeah he's the expert here thank
you oh no I'll hold on to it
Donnie Dr Nolan he's not really a doctor
he's a fool do you need any help
wow and I just haven't been me for the
last six between you I could actually
see your face that's crazy
[Music]
about the time now which is what started
all I kind of wish the thumbnail was
better like you think it could be better
what he's doing is actually really cool
the Domino makes me feel like I'm stupid
yeah good point
um thumbnail does it's just I guess what
do you do though also why is it a kid
there hasn't been a single kid who got
the surgery yet
I mean it has 51 million views yeah he
knows what he's doing it's Mr Beast like
Mr Beast he he like that's like his main
thing his thumbnail game yeah yeah like
even more than the content itself but
it's just it is interesting like look at
this [__] kid
I feel like he just asked like an AI
make the best thumbnail possible and
this thumbnail is the best thumbnail
literally possible but we don't know why
right that's the thing is like I feel
like his Gene he's so many layers yeah
he's a genius
100 100 yeah
he's been my rock through all this
before the operation you mentioned the
first thing you wanted to see was your
son seeing him seeing his face well that
will be the second thing you see after
my face
that's what I miss you know you're gonna
make me cry no no you're good man you're
good you're really good man all right oh
my God man
there you go
he's like damn son you gained a lot of
weight
damn son y'all need a shave or something
boy I just gotta put the cataracts back
then boy God damn
I remember you looking much better than
this son
you have really Let Yourself Go
crying I can see everybody's crazy
feature now it's a little blurry with my
tears coming out you guys you better
learn now I'm a [__] demon okay it is
what it is
[Music]
Jeremiah has been blinded his right eye
since he was born and it's affected his
vision that's so sad excited he's living
his full life since he was born with
blind to one eye for no goddamn reason
like that's so funny David dobrik's
friend yeah exactly am I right good one
chestnuts
you know I was gonna I was gonna hit it
during the crying right there but
I don't know man I don't even know what
you're saying dude just
I haven't even seen that part but what
we were just watching with the dude with
the Sun
he's saying you killed his setup
does that way because Jeremiah was born
with cataracts his right eye never
received light and that means that this
surgery only has a 50 chance of working
I think we go ahead and get it underway
and then we'll just talk post off and
while Jeremiah's surgery was underway I
met another young man named Satchel did
they tell you I was gonna be here no
good he had poor vision from birth and
almost lost his entire Vision after a
go-karting accident all I see is like
blur in color I can barely see like the
shapes obviously you can't drive right
no I cannot and this is did you not hear
he got in a go-kart accident he couldn't
drive even if he could see
it's like when he could see he couldn't
drive I see I mean maybe he wasn't
responding until we got blind he wasn't
in the first place
I'm just not rushing to get this guy
back behind the wheel what if he he got
blue shelled yeah it's possible it was a
blue shell injury
why we're doing this blindness can take
away parts of your life and you know I
want to drive since I can't drive I'm
just at home good luck we'll see you
after the procedure he mentioned
multiple times he really wants to drive
after his fixes his eyesight so I'll see
you at the end of the video when we
surprise him with a brand new Tesla but
oh my God
don't get
he's trying to kill him
a brand new Tesla the man couldn't even
handle a go-kart
hey that that's funny like I get yeah
that's funny I get the angle all right
at the angle this surgery was successful
[Music]
let's do this how'd it go
I'm good yeah are you excited
cheers
[Music]
to make this day even more special since
you're about to graduate high school and
go to college we want to give you fifty
thousand dollars to put towards College
fifty thousand oh my God
I think I'm gonna wrap it up are you
bailing on me bro
we've almost made it through I'm bailing
on this show I'm just in Goblin mode I
can't help yeah I don't want to sit here
through this
but also I have work too I didn't know
we were going to go on from 10 a.m until
2 pm we've been going four hours three
and a half so y'all really can't
complain because I went four hours okay
who was complaining I don't want to see
any threads crying about over the
integers
oh my God
well I just want to finish there's only
like two minutes left in the video
that sounds like a long time let me
finish
I'm gonna finish in two minutes and then
we'll go let me finish okay I'm just
afraid
don't be afraid you already been here
for the worst you're here for the
[__] chestnuts moment you can't top
that if you leave it's gonna get worse
okay yeah you're you're the damn holding
back the I've done this natural surgery
went helped in anything here
ha now I don't even see any blur
[Music]
all right here's the fastest car in the
world
good luck out there dude
I mean Tesla plaid now it's fine time to
write the past I think the last time he
could see he crashed and got blind
you see it
how are you feeling bro
three weeks later okay cars I mean at
this rate two two minutes will take us
like five hours no no no
we're now down to one minute 40 seconds
I have a surprise for you do you mind
putting on this blindfold hold on hold
on
Satchel take off your voice
[Music]
can I buy another one
are they all getting Teslas
no just this dude I think
oh they have a one Tesla per video
budget is it in relation to how they
went blind like everyone gets a
difference like this dude got stabbed in
the face so we're giving him a giant
Samurai
some high quality uh chefs now we're
getting him uh what was the the guys we
made the the meat in the boot stake in
the boot chainmail oh uh uh Cold Steel
yeah finest finest still in the world
literally I'm sorry I gotta go back to
the shot because this looks like he's
about to run him down someone gonna make
an edit right just like this to one of
those clips for a Tesla hits like a doll
yeah look at this [__] they're about to
run this poor guy down take off your
Vlog bowls
foreign
[Laughter]
keep your hands off my [__] car David
dobrik's in the parking lot with the
excavator yeah right
literally I cannot put into words have
you ever driven a car before no perfect
I love how we're letting you guys who
couldn't see a couple weeks ago drive us
don't hit the ground
[Applause]
the music
[Music]
actually we have uh so he needs to get
his license we actually have footage of
him when he first did his driver's ed go
ahead roll that with footage inside the
car during his driver's ed
driver education
go ahead and roll it please
give us go ahead please roll the footage
[Music]
laughs
it's a miracle
dreams do come true
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
driving's not that much fun as a kid
chat said nice visual representation of
the show
because unfortunately do you believe
half the population with curable
blindness doesn't have access to this
surgery so I wanted to provide this to
as many people as possible
[Music]
they just got honorable mentions
oh wait but is this is the is it a
thousand per country or a thousand total
I think it's total oh okay I think he
probably under quite a few more if you
hadn't given the one kid the Tesla dude
he could have done like five more
surgeries yeah
is it that expensive really only five
more I was thinking way more than that
it said six to twelve thousand in the
U.S okay uh maybe you're right uh but
he's like she's like Oscar Schindler at
the end of Schindler's List where he's
like this ring could have saved five
more people bro there's five people walk
around blind because this kid needed to
get a Tesla she's gonna [__] put in a
ditch anyway let's be real we don't know
I mean okay you're right we don't know
that it's self-driving oh yeah we know
how good that self-driving right the
thought of him crying saying I could
have saved Morris so
but we're also going to other places
around the world because unfortunately
nearly half the population with curable
blindness doesn't have access to this
surgery by the way you gotta love how
it's like USA and all these other third
world countries where people can't get
this I wanted to provide this I mean as
many people as possible [__] Mexico
Honduras
Indonesia Brazil Vietnam Kenya because
any other [__] country they are
goddamn people don't walk around with
curable blindness
disgusting wait
I just yeah I thought I remembered and I
just looked it up and
uh Mexico does have Universal Health
Care
yeah the surgery is covered there or
something maybe but maybe it's just a
big line I don't know or yeah the way
they're not the they're not like a super
rich country and also they're like
completely
going through hard times right now if I
know we have plenty of Mexican fans if
uh
if you know what the situation is down
there explain in the chat
because I would think they would be able
to get it Jamaica
yeah a thousand right there we gotta we
got the hotel going
oh is this copyrighted music
how many fingers you see
yeah let's go cheers
[Music]
everything
we said in Brazil we have public health
care but it would be a long long line
for a surgery like this so maybe yeah
okay yeah by the way so this lady was
the thousandth and then there's like a
whole line of people outside he's like
go home everything give that kid a Tesla
everybody go home
there it is I mean obviously you know
I'm making I'm making jokes but great
job there bud yeah
[Music]
someone said as a Mexican I have no idea
appreciate that
very helpful appreciate that
all right guys I mean look what can I
say should we add Rebecca Black and
no just Rebecca blacks people don't know
just keep a low profile yeah yeah the
chestnuts roasting I mean also it is a
guest episode and
let's don't take that away from me yeah
exactly
the Black episode
damn you know really
if somebody said Mexican uh Mexican food
Soldier here Healthcare is free however
you do have to register and sometimes
the waiting list is really long
depending on and it just disappears
still better than here on the treatment
at least you can get it this kid was
like blind from birth
lots of work
also the 6K how can it be 6K that has to
be like an arbitrary pumped up number by
like uh Healthcare like whatever
probably 6 30. oh doctors expensive bro
10 minute procedure yeah
yeah
because just because it could be that
expensive you think yeah the thing is
being a doctor is super expensive first
of all they're malpractice insurance is
insane the the equipment you need to do
this kind of surgery is insanely
expensive you know what I mean it's like
I don't know yeah and then don't even
talk about how much debt these doctors
are probably in too each doctor comes
out of med school with like a million
dollars of debt
right it's all bad
all right guys roast those chestnuts at
home we're gonna sign out today is um
Monday so we'll be back on Wednesday
with the steamies
and we'll be adding
um our chestnuts moment so the most
cringed category you can vote on that
well that'll be honest that'll be next
year's yeah and yeah cheers
there's no sleeping in the mountain
no clips from this episode by the way
Clippers
no you yeah no you can do it I'm kidding
all right guys thanks for watching thank
you to Rebecca Black y'all check her out
over links and stuff
in the description and uh her album's
coming out Super Trooper support Friends
of the show Rebecca the black we love
her I said call it the Black Monday
episode
all right guys and I'm so sorry the
cutie you know what I don't know what's
wrong with me I have a problem where
this has happened to me a few times in
my life and I have a problem you guys
I I don't know why so don't be ableist I
don't know why you disbacing that option
it could be no that's it it's Tourette's
no it is bad to also just blindly say uh
yes that's what it is no listen I was on
2 A.M I had Tourette's did you just say
blindly say damn
[Music]
no I do apologize to cutie that I I see
the pain she's in and that was just
I I take it very seriously and I support
her
um all the way okay I have Tourette's
thank you bye
[Music]
amazing